HEAR ME.
ALRIGHT.
MY NAME IS DAVID CHIU ON THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE.
OUT OF OUR STATE CAPITOL I WANT
TO WELCOME ALL OF YOU ON FRIDAY
MARCH THE NINTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. TO TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISES.
AND CONCERNING CHALLENGES AND
SOLUTIONS AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. WHENEVER JUST FIRST SAY
THAT I IT'S GREAT FOR ME TO BE
HERE AND SAMBAR MEDINA I WANNA
THANK MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GOMEZ REYES FOR INVITING
US TO HER DISTRICT.
DISCUSS THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC I UNDERSTAND WE ARE ONE
BLOCK WITHIN YOUR DISTRICT AND A
BLOCK AWAY FROM. VICE CHAIR
COMMITTEES DISTRICT.
AND I WANT TO THANK AND WELCOME
OUR VICE CHAIR MISTER STEINORTH
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY. ALSO TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK THE
STAFF OF THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE AND IN
PARTICULAR JOSH CANDELARIA FOR
pI'M GONNA MAKE  FEW YET GIVEN
UP FOR THEM.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A FEWOPENING
REMARKS AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR A FEW REMARKS
AND THEN WE HAVE A SERIES OF
PANELS. ARTS REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE HOUSING CRISIS
LOOKS LIKE HERE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE HERE IN SAMBOR MEDINA.
LET ME FIRST START BY SAYING
THAT IN EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE WE ARE EXPERIENCING THE
MOST INTENSE HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
FROM THE SAN DIEGO BORDER UP TO
THE OREGON BORDER FROM THE COAST
ALL THE WAY INLAND. WE'RE ALL
SEEN THE HOUSING CRISIS BUT I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS HAS LOOKED.
DIFFERENTLY DOT IN DIFFERENT
CORNERS OF THE STATE.
I REPRESENT SAN FRANCISCO MY
CITY HAS THE HIGHEST RENTS AND
HOME PRICES
IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT WHAT OUR HOUSING CRISIS
LOOKS LIKE I KNOW BEARS SOME
SIMILARITY TO WHAT WE MAY BE
EXPERIENCING HERE. UP THERE
PROBABLY SOME CRITICAL
DIFFERENCES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
FOR US AS POLICY MAKERS TO
UNDERSTAND.
LAST YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
REALLY MODERN HISTORY.
I'M VERY PROUD THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A HISTORIC PACKAGE OF
FIFTEEN BILLS.
YOU BEGIN TO ADDRESS A HOUSING
CRISIS.
ARE ON THE FUNDING SIDE WE
ESTABLISH FOR THE FIRST TIME A
PERMANENT SOURCE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FUNDING. WE HAVE PLACED
ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT THIS YEAR
A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BOND FOR
MORE INVESTMENTS IN HOUSING
AROUND THE STATE. WE ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF MEASURES THAT HOLD CITIES
AND COUNTIES MORE ACCOUNTABLE TO
BUILD HOUSING. AS WELL AS TO
STREAMLINE THE HOUSING CREATION
PROCESS BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW HOW
LONG THAT COULD TAKE.
BUT AS I AND ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID LAST YEAR.
THE WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE THUS
FAR I THINK IS THE FIRST AND
GOOD STEP.
WE MIGHT SAY AS A DOWN PAYMENT
ON THE PROBLEM BUT AS ANYONE
KNOWS A DOWN PAYMENT REPRESENT
SOLVING TWENTY PERCENT YOUR
PROBLEM. WE GOT EIGHTY PERCENT
TO GO.
WE ARE STILL EXPERIENCING THE
HIGHEST RENTS THE HEIST HOME
PRICES WERE SEEN.
A HOMELESSNESS CRISIS ALL OVER
THE STATE RACINE CONVICTION AND
ATTENDED CRISES ALL OVER THE
STATE. AYE AND WE GOT WORK TO DO
AND SO OF LAST YEAR WE STARTED A
SERIES OF HEARINGS AROUND
CALIFORNIA WE DID PROBABLY ABOUT
A HALF A DOZEN LAST YEAR. THIS
IS THE FIRST HEARING OF THIS
TYPE THAT WE'RE DOING THIS YEAR
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND AT A MORE
LOCAL LEVEL. WHAT DOES THE
HOUSING CRISIS LOOK LIKE WHAT
DOES THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
LOOK LIKE AND AGAIN I WANT TO
REALLY THANK ELOISE? NOT JUST
FOR BEING SUCH A HOUSING
CHAMPION I HERE AND IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT FOR.
INVITING US AND WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT DOING THIS FOR
MANY MONTHS AND I'M GLAD WE WERE
ABLE TO.
CHO INSIDER SCHEDULES TO JOIN
SO HOT SO WITH THAT.
AGAIN REALLY PLEASED TO BE HERE
LOOK FOR TO HEARING FROM OTHER
WITNESSES AND NOW I'M GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GOMEZ RESTS.
GIVE IT UP FOR HER.
I DO WANT TO THANK.
CHAIR OF THE.
HOUSING.
ME TOO DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
MY MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU.
SPEND AN ABSOLUTE CHAMPION WHEN
IT COMES TO HOUSING.
AND IT
HE HE'S RIGHT FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE INLAND EMPIRE VERY
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT SAN
BERNARDINO. HAVING HIM COME AND
JOIN US AND I WANTED HIM TO HEAR
FROM ALL OF YOU ABOUT THE
ISSUES.
THAT WE FACE HERE IN SAN
BERNARDINO BUT ALSO SOME OF THE
INNOVATIVE IDEAS THAT WE HAVE
PUT TOGETHER AS A COUNTY AND IS
INDIVIDUAL. A DEVELOPER'S TECH
TO SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS HERE
IN OUR DISTRICT.
IT'S A.
I DO WANT YOU TO THE HOPE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU WAS
ELECT FIRST ELECTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AS INDICATED
HE REPRESENTS SAN FRANCISCO.
BEFORE THAT HE WAS THE.
WHAT POSITION DID YOU HAVE WITH
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS?
APPARENTLY A HEADED UP THAT
BOARD THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S WE'RE
NOT HERE TO TALK ABOUT ME. YOU
KNOW BUT THAT IS IMPORTANT I
WANT YOU TO KNOW WHO IT IS THAT
IS BRINGING THIS COMMITTEE TO US
TODAY.
BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
PANELISTS IN ADVANCE FOR TAKING
THE TIME ALSO TO BE HERE WITH
US.
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT HEARING FROM
YOU AND LEARNING FROM YOU ABOUT
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE. AND HOW IT
IS AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN PARTNER WITH YOU.
STILL PLAGUE US
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU.
ASK MY VICE CHAIR OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE SOMEONE WHO I THINK
MANY YOU KNOW WELL.
WHO HAILS FROM THIS REGION?
YOU KNOW I WILL SAY THAT.
WHILE ALL OF US ARE WATCHING
WHAT CONVERSATIONS ARE NOT
HAVING HAPPENING BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IN
WASHINGTON DC. ARE I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT.
THINGS ARE QUITE DIFFERENT IN
THE STATE CAPITAL.
WE MAY NOT ALWAYS AGREE.
BUT WE HAVE HAD MANY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS ON WHAT WE NEED TO
DO ON A LOT OF ISSUES.
VERTICALLY HOUSING AND.
IT'S BEEN A REAL PLEASURE TO
HAVE OUR VICE CHAIR.
IN YOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MARC
STEINORTH.
AT FIRST I I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO THE SERGEANTS.
THAT HAVE COME HERE WITH WITH
DAVID AND WITH ELOISE TO PROTECT
EVERYONE HERE THAT'S WONDERFUL
AND I THINK YOU TO DAVID TO LISA
FOR MAKING THE TRIP DOWN HERE TO
BRING THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
IT'S.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT DAVID M.
ALLUDED TO HE AND I HAVING LOTS
OF CONVERSATIONS AND IT'S IT'S
INTERESTING HIS PERSPECTIVE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO IS IS ABSOLUTELY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE INSANITY NOW AND
IT'S. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REALIZE THAT CALIFORNIA'S IT
VERY LARGE AND DIVERSE STATE AND
HOUSING NEEDS WHEN WE'RE
DISCUSSING LEGISLATION IN
SACRAMENTO.
WE CAN'T ALWAYS HAVE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL SO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN TO
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES. I'M HEREIN SEEMED
MEDINA COUNTY I TEASE DAVID ON A
REGULAR BASIS OUR CHALLENGES ARE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN AS HE
HAS A LOT OF REALLY SKILLED
WORKERS. THAT HAVE GREAT PAYING
JOBS FROM SILICON VALLEY MCKAY
BRING THOSE TO. YOU KNOW AS WE
BRING THE COMMITTEE DOWN HERE WE
WE HAVE LOTS OF LAND WE HAVE
LOTS OF LAND WE CAN DEVELOP LOTS
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AS WE DISCUSS A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT HOW DO WE
MAKE HOUSING AFFORDABLE FOR
EVERYONE BY INCREASING SUPPLY.
SO I'M I'M PLEASE THAT WERE HERE
AND I LOOK FOR THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY THANK YOU.
GREAT AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO JUST DIVE RIGHT IN I'M GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO.
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GOMEZ REYES TO.
REDUCE THE FIRST SET OF SPEAKERS
AROUND TENANTS AND. THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE AND THEN I WILL.
INTRODUCE THE NEXT SPEAKERS OUT
THERE WILL HAVE SO WITH THAT.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE LISA
COOLEY.
THAT DOES AND ARE SUPERVISOR
JOSIE GONZALEZ IF YOU'LL PLEASE
COME.
AND HAVE A SEAT.
IS LISA HERE.
COME ON IN LISA.
COME ON OVER AND HAVE A SEAT.
CLEARLY NO CONVERSATION
SURROUNDING HOMELESSNESS ON
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
CAN'T HAPPEN UNLESS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE. CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THOSE.
WHO ARE TENANTS?
PEOPLE THEMSELVES.
OUR FIRST PANELIST WILL BE LISA
LEAVE ANO'S A RESIDENT TO
BLOOMINGTON.
CURRENTLY LIVES IN ONE OF THE
AREAS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
LISA I HAS BEEN A RESIDENT OF
BLOOMINGTON GROVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SINCE APRIL SIXTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
SEVERAL YEARS PRIOR.
SHE WAS STUDYING CRIMINAL LAW ON
LOOKING FORWARD TO RECEIVING HER
DEGREE.
UNFORTUNATELY SHE WAS A VICTIM
OF IDENTITY THEFT
S. DERAILED HER EDUCATION PLANS.
SPIRALED HER INTO DIRE FINANCIAL
STRESS.
IF FORCED HER TO LIVE OUT OF HER
CAR FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS.
PRIOR TO MOVING INTO THE
BLOOMINGTON GROVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SHE HAD BEEN ON A WAIT LIST FOR
VARIOUS AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
LIVING IN BLOOMINGTON GROW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS HAD A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON HER LIFE. IT
IS PROVIDED HER WITH STABILITY
THE STABILITY SHE NEEDS
TO REBUILD HER LIFE.
SHE ALSO ENJOYS SPENDING TIME
WITH HER FOUR CHILDREN OF
PARTICIPATING IN COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT AND MINISTERING WITH
HER CHURCH.
LISA.
THANK YOU. MIGHT APPRECIATE THE
I DO NOT TAKE FOR GRANTED JUST
WITNESSED SPEAK ON THE BEHALF OF
THOSE THAT ARE. HOMELESS IN THAT
THIS WHERE SOME LIFESTYLE.
I JUST WANNA SAY WILL QUICKEN
YOU PRETTY MUCH SUMMED IT UP
WELL.
I WAS THE ABSOLUTE PERSON THAT
WERE VERY HARD.
TO MAKE A LIVING MY CHILDREN AND
MYSELF ME AND MY HUSBAND AND.
I DID EVERYTHING I WAS SUPPOSED
TO YOU KNOW TO.
BECOME ESTABLISH MAKE SURE MY
CHILDREN AND I HAD THE WHOLE THE
WHOLE NINE YARDS
BUT HIM THAT SHE SAID I DIDN'T
EAT THAT FIT ME AND.
I WANT YOU GUYS ALL THINK ABOUT
WHAT IT WOULD BE LIKE TO
ESTABLISH YOURSELF.
WORK VERY HARD.
AND DO EVERYTHING YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO IT. WHEN HE BIT.
HAPPENS IN YOUR LIFE THAT SO
CATASTROPHIC THAT.
YOU DO YOUR HOMELESS A LOS YOU
CARS A LAWS ALL THAT YOU WORK SO
HARD FOR FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS
ARE JUST. WIPED OUT JUST LIKE
THAT.
SO WHEN EVERYBODY GET A VISION
OF WHAT THAT WOULD BE DO YOU.
I'M FIFTY FOUR YEARS OLD NOW.
SO.
BASED BE HAVING TO START OVER
WITH MY LIFE.
I'M LESS TODAY THAN I HAVE WHEN
I WAS EIGHTEEN I BEEN NOW ALL MY
OLD SYSTEM SEE.
BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID WITH
THE GRACE OF GOD AND THE GLORY
OF GOD AND I AM A CHRISTIAN SO.
I HAD TO PUT GOD FIRST BECAUSE
I.
I TOLD WE ALL MY FAITH IN
EVERYTHING IS IN GOD BUT THESE.
BEEN IN THESE APARTMENT SAYS
GIVE ME A LIFE.
BEFORE THAT WAS LIVE IN ACCORD
SHE SAID.
IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WAS
UNABLE TO LIVE BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE HOMELESS.
YOU'RE NOT LIVING LIFE.
YOU'RE JUST THINKING ABOUT
SAFETY YEARS THINKING OF OUR
OKAY WERE MIKE AND HE THEIR
SOULS ó THERE'S.
NO YOU KNOW THINGS TO COOK WITH
IT.
YOU GOT THE PROCESS ROUTE EVERY
DAY THERE'S ELEMENT OF. CRIMINAL
GUILT THINGS GOING ON AROUND YOU
ALL THE TIME SO. I NEVER HAD ANY
PIECE OF JOY REST.
BECAUSE I'M CONSTANTLY ABOUT
CARDIGANS NO FOR WINDOWS JUST
TRYING TO SOME BY.
IN PEOPLE WHO.
.
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT'S
MONIES ON THE STREET.
EVEN NECESSARY CHOOSE THE ARTIST
RIYADH MENCHU'S WOULD BE ALMOST
THAT THEY WAKE UP ONE DAY AND
JUST SAY. WHAT THEY ARE GONNA
DRIVE HOME TO SEE IF THAT WORKS
UP?
THAT'S NOT WHAT HE DID YOU KNOW
BUT. EVEN YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND
THAT TO JUDGE.
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW WELL ONE
P. CHECK WAY.
AND WE'RE ALL ONE CABS DROP WIKI
BEEN AWAY.
FROM BEING THAT SAME PARTICULAR.
BUT BEING ABLE TO LIVE IN THE
APARTMENT.
NOW ALLOWS ME TO GET THAT JURY.
PEACE
AND THE REST OF OUR RESIDENTS
LONG HIM MADE HIM TO SLIP SLEEP.
AND SO LONG BECAUSE AGAIN YOU'RE
IN SURVIVAL MODE.
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO LIVE YOU'RE
JUST JEALOUS OF RIGHT.
I AM AND I'M JUST SO GLAD TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO MY OWN RESEARCH.
MY OLD KITCHEN.
AND NOW HAVE THE WORRY ABOUT.
I MIGHT NOT EVEN WAKE UP TO TO
IT
TODAY.
OR TOMORROW.
SO I. I WANT TO PUT A FACE ON
THE REAL HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT
ARE OUT THERE.
YOU CAN'T GO BY THE WAY THEY
LOOK.
BECAUSE I WOULD GO MY KOREAN
GRAB MY CLOSE THE DOOR MONO BUT
EVEN KNOW.
SO YOU CAN ENOUGH SOON SUPPLIES
NOW BY THE WAY THEY DRESS.
THE KEY WINNING JUST NEEDS OF
LOW THIS IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU GUYS CONTINUE TO BUILD
THESE APARTMENTS.
THE GAO THING ABOUT THE HOMELESS
COULD THIS GET HAPPENED ANYBODY
ELSE'S.
AND I THINK GOD EVERY DAY.
EVERYDAY FOR. THESE APARTMENTS
AND THAT THEY ARE BEING BUILT
AND THEY TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION A. S. CHANGE.
MY LIFE AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE
WOULD BE.
IF I HAD BEEN ABLE TO MOVE THESE
APARTMENTS.
I THINK GO FOR THAT EVERY DAY.
THANK YOU
.
I JUST LIKE TO MAKE ONE COMMENT
THANK YOU FOR FOR SHARING THAT
WE WE LIKE TO START THESE
HEARINGS IS WE'VE BEEN GOING
AROUND THE STATE.
WITH REAL STORIES ODDS WANTING
TO HEAR FROM THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND HEAR FROM OUR
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US TO
BE REMINDED OF WHAT.
FOLKS ARE REALLY EXPERIENCING
BY IN THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE HAD
SOME FAIRLY INTENSE
CONVERSATIONS OF THIS PAST YEAR
ABOUT THE PLATE FACING TENANTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE ONE
PAYCHECK AWAY.
THIS YEAR MANY OF US ARE ALSO
FOCUSED ON THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS AND I THINK YOU. HAVE
FIVE SHARED SOME ABOUT THAT IT
WILL CERTAINLY HEAR MORE ABOUT
IT BUT I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR FOR SHARE.
THE.
IT IS TRULY A AN OPPORTUNITY.
AS WAS JUST STATED. TO BE ABLE
TO PUT A REAL FACE.
ON WHAT WE MANY TIMES OF.
IMAGINE BUT IN A BLUR TO BE.
ONE WE SEE ACROSS THE STREET
SOMEONE WE SEE IS WHAT.
IN A NEWSPAPER OTHER SOMEONE WE
SEE ON TELEVISION IN THE NEWS.
BUT TO BRING IT HOME IN TO MAKE
IT RELATIVE TO.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO LIVE RIGHT
NEXT TO US AND.
GOD'S GRACE LIVE RIGHT NEXT TO
US IS TRULY ON A A MISSION A
PATH THAT WE HAVE LONG BEEN ON.
AND TODAY PFIZER SUPERVISOR I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU.
MOST OF US KNOW YOU BUT THERE
WILL BE OTHERS WHO WILL BE
WATCHING WHO WANT TO KNOW WHO IS
THIS WONDERFUL WOMAN SPEAKING.
PERRANCE SO I WANT TO INTRODUCE
JOE SICKENS ALLAH'S SABATINO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR THE FIFTH
DISTRICT.
JOSIE HAS BEEN A RESIDENT OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY HER ENTIRE
LIFE.
SPENDING TIME IN COLTON DEL ROSA
SAMPOERNA DINO AND NOW IN
FONTANA.
COUNTY SUPERVISOR GONZALEZ HAS
SPENT SEVEN YEARS IN PUBLIC
SERVICE WITH THE CITY OF
FONTANA.
MOST OF WHICH SHE SERVED A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER. AND CHAIRED THE
FONTANA REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND
THE FONTANA DOWNTOWN
REVITALIZATION TASK FORCE.
HER DEDICATION TO ENHANCING AND
STRENGTHENING HER COMMUNITY IS
NOT ONLY ADMIRABLE BUT
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE AREAS
THAT SHE CONTINUES TO SERVE.
SUPERVISOR GONZALEZ IS THE FIRST
LATINA ELECTED TO SERVE AS A
STAND BRING TO DO YOU KNOW
COUNTY SUPERVISOR. AT THE SECOND
WOMAN TO SERVICE SUPERVISOR FOR
THE FIFTH DISTRICT.
AFTER SHATTERING THE GLASS
CEILING AND ENTERING THIS ROLE
SHE NOW FOCUSES DILIGENTLY ON
HELPING CREATE MORE LOCAL JOBS.
PROVIDING CLEAN DRINKING WATER
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND
DEVELOPING SMART GROWTH FOR
COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
SUPERVISOR JOSIE GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
.
THAT MOST UNDESERVED.
INTRODUCTION I'D LIKE TO IT
THIS TIME WELCOME.
CHAIRMAN CHIU IT IS A PLEASURE
AND AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU UP VICE
CHAIRMAN OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
STEINORTH AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ELOISE GOMEZ REYES WELCOME TO
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY AND
WELCOME TO OUR COUNTY CHAMBERS.
TODAY'S FOCUS.
THE CHALLENGES OF MEETING OUR
RESIDENTS NEEDS
OF ACCESSIBILITY TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ADDRESSING WHAT IS A
NATIONAL TRAGEDY.
HOMELESSNESS.
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ALL.
AS YOU STATED OUR CHAIRMAN CHIU
THAT WE ALL IN THIS STATE.
AND IN THROUGH OUR AWARENESS IN
THIS NATION HAVE BE CALM ACUTELY
AND UNCOMFORTABLY AWARE OF.
WORKING THROUGH INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS AND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
ENTITIES AND OUR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS. ODD
AND ARE CITY UNIFIED A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE DAM THE
JURY NEED OF BED DRESSING
HOMELESSNESS.
THERE IS NO SUCH A THING IN MY
OPINION AS ENDING HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE PEOPLE MAKE.
PERSONAL CHOICES PEOPLE HAVE
ACCIDENTS PEOPLE HAVE THROUGH
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES HAVE
THE.
THE TRAGIC SITUATION OF BECOMING
HOMELESS SO IT IS THROUGH OUR
EFFORTS TO LEARN HOW DO WE
ADDRESS AND HOW CAN WE BEST.
SET UP A SYSTEM WHICH IS.
BEARD AND READY TO PRE VENT
HOMELESSNESS BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
TODAY YOU WILL HEAR FROM MISTY
ENOUGH WINTERS WHOSE OUR DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING. AND SHE
WILL SPEAK TO WHAT I BELIEVE TO
BE THE FLAGSHIP OF OUR
INNOVATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN
BUILDING AND RE. COMMUNITIES
SHE WILL BE TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
BLOOMINGTON GIRL BEEN LILLIAN
COURT.
SENIOR AND LOW INCOME HOUSING A
LIBRARY A PLAYGROUND.
AND A POOL ALL OF THESE
AMENITIES THAT WERE NOT FATAH IN
ANY SHAPE OR FORM PRIOR TO OUR
OPPORTUNITIES AT HOUSING FUNDS.
IT IS THE FIRST DEVELOPMENT OF
ITS KIND IN AN UNINCORPORATED
AREAS CITIES BY FAR HAVE BEEN
VERY AGGRESSIVE IN IN OUR.
PREVIOUS AERO WHEN REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WERE ALIVE AND WELL
CITIES DID A LOT OF NEW OF
REMOVING BLIGHT AND AND REYES
SEEING THE MANY.
OF AND ON OUTDATED NEIGHBORHOOD
AND BEING ABLE TO THEN TO
REBUILD MANY MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THIS GREAT STATE.
TODAY.
WE ARE LOOKING AT MANY OF THESE
TYPE OF HOPEFULLY FUNDED
PROJECTS
TO BE ABLE TO ENABLE THIS TYPE
OF REVITALIZATION IN
REDEVELOPMENT TO TAKE PLACE. AND
WITH THAT SAID WE KNOW IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF THIS
COUNTY HAVE BE. THE NEW
DEVELOPMENT FRONTIERS.
WE ARE DETERMINED TO BE ABLE TO
BE A GOOD PARTNER IN A GOOD
NEIGHBOR TO OUR TWENTY FOUR
CITIES THAT THEY MAY LOOK UPON
WHAT WE ARE DEVELOPING AND
BUILDING. JUST ACROSS THEIR CITY
LIMITS BUT WITHIN THEIR SPHERE
OF INFLUENCE AS SOMETHING THAT
IS POSSIBLE SOMETHING THAT IS
ECONOMICALLY ADVANTAGEOUS IN
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE CONSIDERED
FOR FUTURE ANNEXATION.
YOU WILL ALSO HEAR FROM MISS
MARIA RUSSELL WHO IS OUR
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING AUTHORITY
FOR THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNARDINO.
SHE WILL TALK ABOUT THE MOVE TO
WORK DESIGNATION OF WHICH I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE SHE WILL SPEAK
TO WATERMAN GARDENS ARE OUR
PROJECT THAT IS VERY SUCCESSFUL
WE SUPPORT THIS PROJECT HERE IN
THE CITY OF SAN BERNARDINO. AND
ALSO SHE WILL SPEAK TO
PARTNERING WITH OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OUR WORK FORCE
PROGRAMMING FOR PARENTS.
ALSO I WILL TELL SHARE WITH YOU
THAT AS CHAIR OF THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS I'VE
WORKED VERY HARD ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND MY BOARD MEMBERS.
ARE ON THE ICY H. TWO IN LEADING
THE WAY. TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WE
WORK DILIGENTLY TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR SUB
POPULATIONS OF THE OVER ALL
MAKEUP OF HOMELESSNESS.
IN THOSE SUB SUB POPULATIONS ARE
OUR YOUTH ARE VETERANS ARE
FAMILIES.
CHRONIC HOMELESS THE ONE IN FOR
WHICH IS ONE ONE MILLION EVERY
FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND THE
PLIGHT BUT THEY FACE AS
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN AND ALSO OUR
SENIOR SUBPOPULATION.
BY ENGAGING WITH PRIVATE
DEVELOPERS AND MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN WE HAVE WORKED HARD TO
ADDRESS ELIMINATING THE BARRIERS
TO HOUSING. WE PROMOTE AND
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUED THE
HOMELESS POINT IN TIME COUNTS.
THE DATE FROM THE DATA FROM
WHICH THE HOMELESS POINT IN TIME
COUNTS
JUSTIFY OUR NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES TO CALM.
AND BETWEEN THE YEARS TWENTY ó
SEVEN AND TWENTY SIX
TEAM WE HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
REDUCING OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION.
AND.
AND ALSO.
UP BY APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
PERCENT
HOWEVER WE NEED TO KEEP IN MIND
IS I GET INTO OUR CHALLENGES.
THAT WE ARE.
NEIGHBORS TO ORANGE COUNTY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WAS WE KNOW IS IS
OUR LARGEST COUNTY AND. AND WE
ARE THE RECIPIENTS
OF THEIR HOMELESS A BETTER.
TRANSITIONAL MIGRATION ALSO
THERE IS A HIGHER COST OF LIVING
IN OUR NEIGHBORING COUNTIES AND
WE ARE EXTREMELY ASSESSABLE. WE
ARE EXTREMELY LARGE WE ARE
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SQUARE MILES
AND OUR CHALLENGES ARE NO
DIFFERENT THAN THE REST OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE BEAUTIFUL
WEATHER.
YOU WOULD THINK WHY WITH THE
WEATHER BE SUCH A CHALLENGE WHEN
PEOPLE WANT TO COME AND SPEND
THEIR TOURISM DOLLARS TO COME
HERE WILL TELL YOU WHAT THE
HOMELESS LOVE OUR WEATHER TO.
AND THEY ARE LOOKING FOR PLACES
TO BE ABLE TO CALL HOME.
WE HAVE WE HAVE.
A HIGH. DENSITY.
HOUSING NEED.
WE HAVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
THROUGH PLANTED GROWTH THROUGH
ADDRESSING AND IN BRINGING OUR
TWENTY FOUR CITIES ON BOARD WITH
YOUR GUIDANCE AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN WHICH WE CAN UNITE
WITH ONE UNITED GOAL. BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HAPPENS IN
NORTHERN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
OR IN SOUTHERN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY.
IT ULTIMATELY IMPACTS ALL OF THE
OTHER COUNTIES AROUND US NO
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HAPPENS IN
OTHER COUNTIES IMPACTS COSTS SO
BEING ABLE TO LIFT EITHER
THROUGH THE RAIN ON NUMBERS OR
LOOK AT HOW DO WE BALANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH MARKET
RATE HOUSING. AND HIGH AND LOW
DENSITY TYPE OF OF DEVELOPMENTS
IS KEY.
IN CLOSING I WOULD SAY.
THAT.
WHETHER IT BE THROUGH A NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM THE S. B. TO
WERE OTHER POLICIES THAT WERE
ADOPTED AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S
HOUSING PACKAGE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO ASSIST THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND HERE IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY WE DO MORE THAN BUILD
HOUSING.
WE BUILD A WHOLE COMMUNITIES
WE HOUSE OUR HOMELESS
WITH PARTNERS LIKE THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. AND OUR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE SUPPORT
FROM ALL OF OUR COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE IN THE HOUSE
TODAY I WANT TO SAY I SAW
GOODWILL INDUSTRIES IN THE HOUSE
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT THEY
ARE A GREAT PARTNER. AND AT THIS
TIME I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO ALL OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND
WELCOME.
SO I WANTED TO ASK
YOU.
EASY OR HOW DIFFICULT WAS IT NO
DON'T DON'T LEAVE YET SUPERVISOR
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU AS WELL.
HOW EASY OR HOW DIFFICULT WAS
IT FOR YOU TO FINALLY?
BE ACCEPTED INTO THIS HOUSING
PROGRAM
I FIND HOUSING.%
IS VERY DIFFICULT.
BECAUSE.
URIAH THIS FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
AND I WAS OF A WAITING LIST OF
THE WILLINGNESS OF THE WINNING.
AND.
I WOULD GO TO APARTMENTS AND
THEY'D SAY WELL IT'S A WILL I
WANT TO GET ON THE WITNESS IN.
OF NO BIG FACTOR IS THE SET OF
WITNESSES CLUBS.
YOU KNOW MAYBE FIVE YEARS LONG
WAY EVEN IF YOU WANTED TO GET ON
THE WAITING LIST. IT WASN'T
CLOSE BECAUSE THEY HAD SO MANY
PEOPLE ON THERE YOU CAN GET ON
THE.
SO WHILE YOU'RE WAITING ON THIS
WAITING LIST.
TING YOU TO LIVE OUT OF YOUR
HOME TO CONTINUE TO BE HOMELESS
SEVEN THE COR YEAH.
YEAH IT'S A IT'S.
IT'S HORRIBLE BECAUSE YOU'RE
DOING WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO IN
ORDER TO.
LIVE IN THE WORLD AND IT'S IT'S
A BE OF MONKS
EVERYBODY ELSE AND TRY TO LIVE A
NORMAL LIFE.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO THAT
WHEN YOU'RE.
A FEELING LIKE AN OUTSIDER
BECAUSE YOU BE ME.
TO FILL THAT WAY BECAUSE.
GOOD.
IT IT BECOMES A WHOLE.
.
THE HOMELESS HAVE THEIR OLD
LIKE.
HUMANITARIAN KNOW THIS BLAME U.
WE COME AS A GROUP.
YOU IDENTIFY WITH ONE ANOTHER SO
YOU'RE NOT EVEN PART OF A
GROWING CITY HIM A RAISE BUT
BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST SO
DISRESPECT.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT RESPECT WE ALL
WANT THE SAME THING.
WE WANT TO BE RESPECTED.
WE ALL WENT HOME TO LIVE IN WILL
ONE JUST QUALITY OF LIFE.
BUT WHEN YOU BECOME A HOMES YOU
KNOW TREATED WITH THAT.
YOU JUST.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
TO TO JUST LIVE OUT OF COURT
LIKE YOU SAID IN.
WATCH A BIT NO PUBLIC RESTROOM
WHERE.
AGAIN JEREMY ABOUT LIKE I RAN
OUT OF.
HE BEAT WHICH IS ASSUMING I'M A
DRUG ADDICT WHO WERE JUST THAT
NOBODY BECAUSE I'M IN THE BACK
FOR WHAT YOU KNOW.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO CLEAN
MYSELF.
AND I'M SURE WHERE FOLKS THAT
REALLY.
YOU KNOW SO WHERE DO WE GO ABOUT
ONE MADMAN HARDER DE.
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY IN TO
REFORM WEEK BUT YOU KNOW THE I
HAD TO DO WOULD HAVE TO DO WHAT
IS.
PEOPLE DON'T MAKE IT EASY
THE DON'T MAKE IT EASIER WHILE
YOU'RE WAITING LIKE A SET.
YOU JUST GOTTA SURVIVE YOU YOU
DON'T LIVE YOUR EXISTING YOU'RE
NOT LIVING.
VELVET YOUR SIX
FULLY.
IN HOUSING.
WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND TO BE
CHANGED IN THE PROCESS?
TWO ALLOWS SOMEONE WHO'S GONE
THROUGH WHICH YOU HAVE GONE
THROUGH. TO BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THE PROCESS SOONER. OR
AND TO TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
FINALLY GET THE HOUSING.
.
WHAT VERY KNOWN AS WHEN I WAS
GOING TO MY PREDICAMENT HOME? I
RECALL LAW THAT LIKE THE TWO OF
ONE AGENCIES
WHICH IS SUPPORT SHOULD BE IN
ALL THE RESOURCES AND THEY LEAD
YOU TO THE NEXT ALL THESE
NUMBERS AND. NOT SEEN IT SO NOT
HELPFUL.
WHAT IS SO FLOWS REALLY CALL
THOSE NUMBERS IT SO WELL THAT?
THAT PRO GROWTH PROGRAM IS NO
LONGER AVAILABLE BECAUSE THE
FUNDS.
WHAT WOULD HAVE LESS WELL SUITED
WITH?
I'M NOT.
YOU KNOW WORKING WITH THE
PRESIDENT NOT ON THE CABINET I
DON'T MAKE THE DECISIONS YOU
KNOW ON.
WHAT IS THE BE ALLIGATOR WOULD
FUNDS GO WEARING HERE AND THERE
AND ALL THAT?
THAT DOESN'T MEAN I'M FIFTY FOUR
YEARS OLD SO MONIES TO HOLD ME.
WE DON'T THE PROGRAM DOESN'T
EXIST ANYMORE OR WE DON'T HAVE
THAT AVAILABLE AND PREDICT THE
FIRST SENIOR SOMEBODY MY AGE IS
REALLY DIFFICULT.
BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY RAISE OUR
KIDS WE'VE ALREADY.
LIVE THEIR LIFE PRETTY MUCH
DURING THAT MIDDLE AGE GROUP
THERE REALLY IS NOT A PROGRAM
OUT THERE.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS GEARED
TOWARDS
THE MALL WITH THE CHILDREN.
WHY RAISE MY KIDS
SO I ALSO FELT LIKE WELL OKAY
NOW BEING PENALIZED BECAUSE I
RAISE MY KIDS IN?
THE ROLLING COLLEGE. MONA MALEK
BICU WHAT DOES POLLS DO THERE
BUT NOW I NEED HOPE.
IN THE MEAN TO YOU THE OTHER BE
DOING DRUGS.
OR DRINKING OR BE IT A LOT OF
THESE THINGS ARE TIGHT TO. WHERE
YOU HAD TO HAVE SUB DUB ISSUES
WELL I'M CHRISTIAN?
I NEVER SMOKED NEVER DRANK IT
NEVER DID DRUGS
SO THAT'S NEVER BEEN A PART IN
MY LIFE AND THAT WAS AN ALLIANCE
THE OLD BUT YEAH I DO DO
EXACTLY.
JUST TO GET IN PROGRAM.
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
PROGRAMS OUT THERE FOR PEOPLE.
AND SPECIFICALLY HOUSING
YES AND NOW DID YOU FIND
TEMPORARY HOUSING AT THE
BEGINNING.
NO.
EVEN THOUGH AND THAT'S WHAT IT
FELLOW TO EVEN WITH THE
SHELTERS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
WHEN YOU GO TO A SHELTER.
HOW YOU AT THE SITE NOW BUT BE
THERE UNDERSERVED?
YOU CAN'T JUST WALK ATME THEY
OWE. KILLER JUST STAY HERE IT
DOES WORK LIKE THAT.
YOU NOTICE THEM IN LINE.
AND YOU BETTER BE IN LINE EARLY
ENOUGH THAT YOU CAN GET IN THE
SHELTER.
AND THEY WANT YOU GET IN THERE.
HOME A LOT OF MIDDLE OF THE
STATE EITHER THERE'S NO ONE.
THERE IS NO POLICE THERE IS
NOBODY THERE TO PROTECT SO YOU
HAVE A LOT OF THEFT.
MY GOD I HOPE AND PRAY THAT YOU
HAD A WAKE UP
RATE TOUR.
BE AN ABUSE BECAUSE THERE IS
NOBODY THERE TO PROTECT YOU.
SCARY.
FOR FOR.
I THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
INFORMATION.
PROVIDER GONZALEZ I KNOW THAT
THERE HAS BEEN.
GREATER EFFORT AT COUNTY TO
COUNTY RELATIONSHIPS.
COULD YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THESE
RELATIONSHIPS AS PARTNERSHIPS.
WITH OTHER COUNTIES WHETHER IT'S
RIVERSIDE YOU TALKED ABOUT LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE.
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THEM AS WELL.
NOT PARTICULARLY.
BECAUSE OF OUR CLOSE PROXIMITY
AND SIMILAR DEMOGRAPHICS AND
IDENTITY AND ALSO BEING KNOWN AS
THE INLAND EMPIRE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IS TRULY.
OUR BEST OF
PARTNERED. PARTNER AND OUR BEST
ALLY.
AND I HOPE THAT THEY LOOK UPON
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY IN THE SAME
LIGHT.
AND BECAUSE WE ALSO.
AND DO A UP BY COUNTY OF A
BOARD REPRESENTATION ON THE
INLAND EMPIRE HEALTH PLAN. WELL
WE ALSO FIND ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
AYE AND AND THERE IN LIES
ANOTHER.
STEP ANOTHER LAYER OF WORKING TO
DRESSING ARE HOMELESS ISSUES AND
OUR HOMELESS OF THROUGH A VERY
NEW AND INNOVATIVE.
.
PLAN OF BRINGING AYE E. H. P.
ONBOARDING I'M SURE YOU WILL BE
HEARING ABOUT THAT LATER. BUT
ULTIMATELY PARTNERING WITH OTHER
COUNTIES OTHER THAN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY HAS NOT HAPPENED. OF.
IRONICALLY HERE THREE WEEKS AGO
TODAY I.
AYE CALLED SUPERVISOR A TODD
SPITZER FROM ORANGE COUNTY AYE
THEY WERE IN THE MIDST OF
ADDRESSING THEIR HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT. AYE IT ALONG THE
SANTA RIVER. AND.
I SPOKE TO HIM AND I ASKED HIM
IF IN FACT THERE MIGHT BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MEET INTO
BEGAN TO DISCUSS ON A REGIONAL.
BASIS WITH A REGIONAL
PERSPECTIVE TO IDENTIFY OUR
CHALLENGES AND WORK TOGETHER TO
FIND THE SOLUTIONS VERY
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS FOR ONE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA TO THE OTHER
AGAIN ESPECIALLY IN THIS COUNTY
WHERE WE HAVE THE HIGH DESERT.
WE HAVE THE LOWER DESERT WE HAVE
THE INLAND VALLEY AND AND THERE
ARE DIFFERENT SETS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT CRY TO
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO
ADDRESSING THE SAME PROBLEM. BUT
YES WE ARE WE WORK CLOSELY A IN
IN MANY RESPECTS WITH RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND WE COULD DEFINITELY
USE A LOT OF HELPING ENCOURAGING
OUR NEIGHBORING COUNTIES.
COME TOGETHER AND PERHAPS WE CAN
FORM A REGIONAL COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS THERE WOULD
ADDRESS ANA ON ON ON A REGIONAL
BASIS AND PERHAPS WE COULD EVEN
COME TOGETHER AND APPLY FOR
FUNDING. IN ARENAS THAT COULD
IMPACT ALL MULTIPLE OF OUR
REGIONS OR WHERE WE COME
TOGETHER SUCH AS IN PRATO DAM
WHERE WE HAVE ORANGE COUNTY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY COMING
TOGETHER. SO THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES THERE.
I WANT TO THANK BOTH OF YOU OUR
FIRST PANELIST THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
BOARD FOR TAKING THIS TIME.
WOULD BE SUPERVISOR HAD ONE
QUESTION FOR YOU I APOLOGIZE
OF YOU REVEREND JUST
REDEVELOPMENT
EARLIER AND I HAVE A BILL. AND
I'M WORKING WITH THE WORKING
GROUP OF OF LEGISLATORS TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT REDEVELOPMENT TO PUT
NO COULD LOOK LIKE. AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNEW WHAT THE
OBJECTIVE THAT WAS WHEN IT WAS
ELIMINATED WITH THE GREAT
RECESSION BUT I'M CURIOUS FROM
YOUR STANDPOINT. WHAT WOULD YOU
WANT TO SEE FROM A NEW VERSION
OF REDEVELOPMENT WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL HERE AND SEVERED INDIA?
CHAIRMAN CHU I WILL TELL YOU
THAT IT IS AN HONOR TO HEAR OB
THE PERSPECTIVE YOU HAVE
RELATIVE TO ADDRESSING OF THE
WORK OUR NEED FOR REDEVELOPMENT
THROUGH YOUR BILL. LET ME SAY TO
YOU THAT WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
PASSED.
OVERSIGHT MISTAKES
AND WHAT ULTIMATELY LEAD TO THE
DEMISE THE DISSOLUTION OF THE
RDAS.
NOT BE REPEATED IN THE FORM OF
CLOSE AUDITS.
DEMANDING ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORTING REGULAR REPORTS ON
WHAT IS BEING DONE WITH THE
FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR SUCH
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY PROJECTS.
THAT THAT THERE BE THAT THERE BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR VIOLATIONS WERE
TRANSGRESSIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
IMPROPER USE OF THOSE FUNDS IN
THAT IN THAT MANNER IT WOULD
INSURE THAT THE AGENCIES THE
CITY'S.
HOWEVER THIS ENDS UP.
COMING INTO A DELIVERY FORM THE
COUNTY I HOPE WILL BE INCLUDED
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO INSULATE AND
PROTECT THOSE AGENCIES THAT IN
FACT ADHERE TO THE RULES AND
DON'T MISS BAND. OR DO ANY KIND
OF FRAUD THAT WOULD INVOLVE
JEOPARDIZING THOSE FUNDS THAT
THEN WOULD INSURE THAT THOSE
DESIGNATED THEM ALLOCATED
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS WOULD BE
USED FOR WHAT. IS THE ACTUALLY
THE AND TAPPED.
SOUNDS LIKE SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S
SOME AGREEMENT WITH THEIR
PERSPECTIVE. I'LL JUST SAY AS A
AS A CLOSING COMMENT.
FOR FOLKS WHO KNEW THAT
REDEVELOPMENT WAS INITIALLY
DESIGNED AS A PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
BLIGHT THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
DEFINITION OF WHAT.
BLIGHT MENTOR WHAT WOULD MEAN
TO ADDRESS POLITE AND SO MONIES
ARE SPENT ON ALL SORTS OF THINGS
IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN ALSO
SPENT ON GOLF COURSES AND STRIP
MALLS AND OTHER THINGS THAT
WOULDN'T SEEM AS CENTRAL TO THAT
GOAL.
WE ARE CONTEMPLATING FOCUSING
ANY REDEVELOPMENT DOLLARS ON
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEFINED AS PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
SO WHAT YOU NEED FOR ROADS OR
PIPES OTHER THINGS SEWER
SYSTEMS.
BUT BUT CERTAINLY I THINK YOUR
PERSPECTIVE HOW TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY IS ONE.
ABOUT.
CLOSELY SO AGAIN THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR
YOUR PERSONAL.
YOU'RE MOST WELL UP WELCOME AND
I TELL YOU YOU CAN COUNT ON ME
TO HELP YOU WITH YOUR BILL
ANYTHING I CAN DO ANY
DEMOGRAPHICS ANY ANY INFORMATION
DATA YOU NEED I WILL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE. I THINK IT IS AWESOME
MANY IT IS IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE A BROAD PERSPECTIVE IN
LOOKING TO THE FUTURE IN
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THE
PEOPLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO S. C. SUPERVISOR IS LEAVING
THE TABLE I'M GONNA INVITE BACK
UP.
OR FIGHT UP THE FOR NEXT
WITNESSES ON A PANEL AROUND
TRANSFORMATIVE HOUSING AND
INNOVATIVE FINANCING IF YOU
WANNA MAKE YOUR WAY. TO THE
WITNESS TABLE WE HAVE.
DEAN OF WINTERS WHO IS THE
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FROM
THE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
HOUSING AGENCY FOR SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. A STEEP UNTIL
THE CEO AND PRESIDENT OF
NATIONAL COMMUNITY RENAISSANCE
MARIA RESSA DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY HOUSING
AUTHORITY. AND KIM CARTER AT THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF TIME FOR CHANGE FOUNDATION IF
YOU WANNA.
MAKE YOURSELVES COMFORTABLE TO
WITNESS TABLE AND.
IN THE MEANTIME ELSE OR JUST
TAKE A MOMENT AGAIN THANK THE
STAFF WHO HELPED PUT THIS
TOGETHER.
ARE OUT SERGEANTS WHO ARE HERE.
FOR FOLKS WHO ARE WONDERING WHO
THE WOMAN SITTING TO THE LEFT OF
MR STEINORTH THIS.
SHE IS THE CHIEF CONSULTANT TO
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE.
WE MAYBE LAWMAKERS BUT WE NEED
OUR STAFF TO ACTUALLY WRITE
THOSE LAWS AND SHE IS MY.
TOP EXPERT ON HOUSING ISSUES
ALSO HERE TO TAKE NOTES ON WHAT
YOU ARE SHARING WITH US I WILL
ALSO MENTION THAT AFTER THE NEXT
PANEL WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO FOLKS.
SO WITH THAT.
.
WE WILL.
I SEE THAT SUPERVISOR JAMES
RAMEAU'S WHO'S JUST COME IN
SUPERVISOR JAMES RAMEAU'S IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SAY A WORD.
OR TO.
THANK YOU.
FOR OPTING TO SAY A FEW WORDS
THANK YOU'RE MISTER CHAIR FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING HERE INTO
THE SEMI MEMBERS SOME SEEN
IMPORTANCE OF HERE BRING IN THE
SUB ISSUES TO SAN BENITO COUNTY.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON A LOT OF
ISSUES HERE WITH HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND OTHERS AND
OTHER PARENTS CAN DEAL WITH
HOMELESSNESS.
BUT THE HOMELESS YOUTH HAS BEEN
A REAL PASSION OF MINE HERE IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS IT YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM. AND TRYING TO BRING
SOME COLLABORATION AND RESOLVE
TO THEM I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL
THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT HEADS
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO THE
FOREFRONT. AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE ALL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER.
AS A REGION AS A STATE NOT
COUNTY TO START TO RESOLVE SOME
OF THESE ISSUES THAT'S WHAT
THANK YOU FOR TAKING.
THE INTEREST IN ADDRESSING THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS IS
GONNA.
WE TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY AND I
CAN'T THINK THE DEPARTMENT HEADS
ENOUGH FOR. WORKING HARD TO
BRING SOME WAS OFFICE ISSUED
SEVENTY OF COUNTY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
IF YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT YOU
TO GO THAT SUPERVISOR JAMES
RAMEAU'S.
IN ADDITION TO IT TO BEING OUR
SUPERVISOR NOW PRIOR TO THAT WAS
THE TRUSTEE WITH SAM AND DEAN OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. AND
ALSO CHAIRED SOMEONE WILL TRY.
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS IS A
GREAT LEADER HERE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING TO THE HEARING
TODAY BLANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALSO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US AT YOUR HOUSE TODAY THANK
YOU.
TO TO CONDUCT THIS MEETING.
YEAH SO WHAT WITH THAT ONE
RETURN IT TO US MISS WINTERS
WE'VE US EACH OF THE PANELISTS
TO TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO.
DESCRIBE THEIR CRISIS AS YOU SEE
HERE IN SAN BERNARDINO ANY
SUGGESTIONS THINGS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US WORK ON. IN
SACRAMENTO.
YOU I AM AGAIN VIEWPOINT IS
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
KEEPING ABOUT WHEN AND HOW I
THINK AGENCY. THAT ENCOMPASSES.
CLICK GROUPS OF THE OFFICE ON
THE SERVICES CAN DEPARTMENT
HOUSING. AND THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY OF THE COUNTY SAN
BERNARDINO.
AND I REALLY THINK DETERMINE
REALLY DESCRIBED VERY CLEARLY IN
THE OPENING REMARKS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
HOUSING. WITHIN THE STATE AND M.
AS.
THE COST OF HOUSING GOES UP AS
YOU HEARD FROM LISA. YOU KNOW
THE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO GET
IMPACTED AYE MEN ARE ON THE
BRINK OF GOING FROM BEING HOUSE
TO HOMELESSNESS. YOU KNOW WAS
VERY FAN AND EQUALLY THOUGH WE
DO NOT HAVE THE RENTAL PRICE AND
HOUSING PRICES UP WHAT'S
EXPERIENCE IN SAN FRANCISCO
THEY'RE EQUALLY AS SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. I'M WITH IN THE
WORLD AS WE GO IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND OTHER AREAS IN THE
COUNTY. MY EXPERIENCE IT'S FUNNY
WHEN YOU BROUGHT UP
REDEVELOPMENT MY EXPERIENCE
ACTUALLY CAME OUT OF CITIES FOR
A MAJORITY OF MY CAREER AND THE
LAST PORTION. IS ONE I'VE WORKED
FOR ACCOUNTING AND IT'S VERY.
AND DIFFERENT AND COMPLEMENTARY
AND WAYS THAT I'M GROUPS MAY OR
MAY NOT REALIZED AND SO THE
FIRST BY THAT I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT WAS HOW DO YOU DEVELOP
HOUSING IN THE POST
REDEVELOPMENT WORLD.
IN THE WORLD OF REDEVELOPMENT
PARTICULARLY IN THIS COUNTY THE
FUNDS WERE SUPPOSED TO BE YEARS
FOR BRICKS AND MORTAR AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE THINGS KIND
OF GOT DIVERGED OFFICE BUILDING
BRICKS AND MORTAR AND
SUSTAINABLE. INVESTMENTS THAT
HELP THE COMMUNITY AND THE LONG
TERM.
AND IN THE INLAND EMPIRE A
NUMBER OF THE TOP.
.
THAT WE.
TAX INCREMENT GENERATORS WERE
ACTUALLY LOCATED IN MANY CITIES
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND SO WHEN
REDEVELOPMENT WENT AWAY.
PARTICULAR ON THE WORLD OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT WAS THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR
FUNDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE STATE.
A SIGNIFICANT OUR RESOURCES
EQUALLY ONE OUT OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE SO WHAT DO YOU DO POST
REDEVELOPMENT. AND THEN TO ME IN
ANYTHING THAT WHERE YOU HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT KIND OF.
STRUCTURAL PARADIGM SHIFT OF
OPERATIONS.
YOU GO THROUGH A PERIOD OF
GRIEF BUT THEY'RE EQUALLY YOU
YOU DON'T GIVE OUT.
IN OUR IN THIS BUSINESS FOR THE
STANDPOINT OF CHAFF BEING FOR
THOSE WHO NEED HOUSING. INTO
WHETHER IT'S ARE WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES ARE SPECIAL NEEDS ARE
HOMELESS POPULATIONS AND YOU
DON'T GIVE UP YOU TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO YOU WORK SMARTER AND
HARDER AND. MAKE THAT DOLLAR GO
FURTHER WEST A FURTHER WIDER AND
DEEPER AND HOW DO WE ACCOMPLISH
MORE OBJECTIVES AND PART OF WHAT
COMES OUT OF THAT. ARE SOME
UNEXPECTED RESOURCES YOU DON'T
LEVERAGING OF TRADITIONAL AND
NONTRADITIONAL RESOURCES AND I
THINK.
IN DECEMBER NINETEEN ARE
COUNTIES EFFORTS THERE'S BEEN A
LOT.
OF DIALOGUE AND COLLABORATIONS
OF HOW DO WE FINANCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE CITIES IF WE ALL
HAVE. IN THEIR POCKETS OF FUNDS
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
UNDERWRITE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT HOW DO WE LEVERAGE
ALL OF THOSE TOGETHER. AND TRY
TO CAPTURE.
BOTH TAX EQUITY DOLLARS THROUGH
BLOCK GRANTS AND TAX CREDITS TO
WITH OUR CITY PARTNERS. TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IT ALSO REQUIRES FROM
THE LOCAL LEADERSHIP AS WE HONOR
COMING FROM CITIES THIS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THE CITY'S WHO WANT TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES WE'RE GOING TO
CHAMPION. HELPING FIGHT SITES
GETTING THROUGH ENTITLEMENT
PROCESSES HELPING WORK WITH
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THEN THE
OTHER PART WHICH I THINK FROM A
AND IT AND IT SHOULDN'T BE AN
UNEXPECTED PARTNERSHIP BUT MANY
TIMES.
HAVING WORKED IN CITIES IN THREE
COUNTIES NOW. M. MANY TIMES THE
COUNTY YOU.
AND THE CITIES HAVE VERY
PARTICULAR THE STAFF AT THE
LOWER STAFF LEVELS DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT EACH OTHER
DOES AND THE COUNTIES HELP A LOT
OF THE LOWER INCOME POPULATIONS.
PARTICULARLY I'M FOR THOSE WERE
LOW INCOME AND HOMELESS ON
SERVICES.
AND THE CONNECTIONS BUT A LOT OF
THOSE FOLKS LIVE IN THE CITIES
AND OR THEY MAY LIVE IN COUNTY
ON A CORPORATE IT BUT HOW DO WE
CONNECT THOSE RESOURCES
TOGETHER.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
BRICKS AND MORTARS IT'S ABOUT
THE ABILITY AND THE LONGEVITY OF
THAT PERSON TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
IT'S CONNECTING THOSE UNEXPECTED
PARTNERSHIPS. AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE LEARNINGS AS WE'VE
GONE IN THE POST REDEVELOPMENT
WORLD. BUT IF YOU DO BRING ON A
REDEVELOPMENT TWO POINT NO BUT I
THINK ONE OF THIS EXPERIENCE
STATUS SABATINO IS HOW DO YOU
LEVERAGE THAT KIND OF MORE STATE
WIDE. IN THAT INTERCONNECTED
WITTY. AND M. FROM OUR
STANDPOINT IN SAMBOR MEDINA
COUNTY BACK IN HOME SAFE TWENTY
TWELVE REMEMBER CORRECTLY.
ONE OF THE THINGS ARE ARE FROM
ONE OF OUR PREVIOUS C. E. O.
SAID AS AS YOU INVEST ITS TO
WHAT AND.
WHERE WE KIND TRYING TO GO WHAT
ARE WE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WERE
NOT JUST GRABBING MONEY AND
SPENDING IT IN ACCORDING TO THE
REGULATIONS HOW DO WE SPEND IT
THAT SHOULD BE WHAT YOU DO? BUT
HOW DO WE GET TO THE OBJECTIVE
WHAT IS THE OBJECTIVE FOR TRYING
TO ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVE IS IT
JUST SPENDING FUNDS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH REGULATIONS. AND
SO IT REALLY GOT INTO THE
CREATION OF A COUNTY WIDE
VISION.
AND THAT REALLY DEFINES WHAT HAS
OUR INVESTMENT PHILOSOPHY POINT
B. WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE.
INTO WHAT AND I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT IS
THE BEST PRACTICES WERE WE DO
WORK WITH. THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE CITIES AND
TRYING TO HAVE. CONNECTIVITY ON
MARKET RATE PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT
AND HOW TO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES BECKETT HELP
FACILITATE HOUSING AND AN
EQUALLY.
EDUCATION IS CRUCIAL FOR SOCIAL
ECONOMIC EQUITIES WITH IN
PARTICULAR CHILDREN AS THEY GROW
AND GIVING THEM CHOICES AND
EDUCATION IS ONE OF THE KEYS.
WE ALSO FOR MARC COUNTY
STANDPOINT IS ON THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WORLD WHAT DO WE DO TO
DIVERSIFY OUR INCOME INVENTORY.
AND OUR SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATIONS AND I I REALLY HAVE
TO THANK THE STATE IN IN KIND OF
A DIALOGUE THAT'S BEEN OCCURRING
BECAUSE WE WERE JUST TALKING
WITH.
ONE OF OUR FOLKS ABOUT.
A LOT OF THE WORLD OF THE STATE
AND HOUSING THE HOUSING AGENCIES
WHO FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING ARE
FOCUSED ON THAT POPULATION A LOT
OF THE CONNECTED BEAUTY AS IT
RELATED TO FROM SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING ARE HOMELESSNESS. REALLY
CAME OUT OF THAT THE DEPARTMENT
ON ON THE HEALTHCARE SIDE ANSWER
STARTING TO BRING THE DIALOGUE
TOGETHER POWER YOU CONNECT THOSE
TOGETHER. AND AS THE STRUGGLE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING JUST
HOUSING IN GENERAL. THE LOWER
SOCIAL ECONOMIC PORTION OF OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION AS THOSE
WHOSE MOST CHALLENGED.
BECAUSE THEY EVEN HAVE A HARDER
ABILITY AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
CIVIC GET INTO HOUSING AND TO
MANEUVER THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
SO I WANTED TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
IN RELATIONSHIP AGAIN TO
PARTNERSHIPS
ARTICLE PARTNERSHIPS IN
PARTNERSHIPS AND IF YOU'RE DOING
HOUSING RIGHT AND YOU'RE DOING
WHAT USED TO BE REDEVELOPMENT
RIGHT YOU'RE NOT JUST CREATING.
HOUSING REVITALIZING A COMMUNITY
YOUR CRAVINGS AND ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT.
AND A SOCIAL ECONOMIC EVENT IN
SOMEBODY'S LIFE AND THE
COMMUNITY IF YOU ARE SUCCESSFUL
AND THAT'S WHAT. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REALLY SHOULD BE
STRIVING FOR EQUALLY WHEN THEY
ARE INVESTING IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND IN THE CITY OF
VICTORVILLE ACTUALLY IN THE
HOMELESS WORLD TO ME THIS WAS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF HOW DO YOU
PARTNER BETWEEN THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY THE COUNTY AND THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. BEING THE CITY
OF VICTORVILLE WHO REALIZE THEY
HAD A HOMELESS POPULATION AND AN
IMPACT.
M. RELATIONSHIP TO THEIR HOMES
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
REACHING OUT TO THE COUNTY AND
ASKING YOU KNOW WE REALIZE THIS
IS A POPULATION THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE SOME HOUSING THERE'S A
LOT OF ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. AND THEY HELP THEM IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF WHAT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY DOES IDENTIFY SITES
FOUND A MOTEL THAT THEY FELT WAS
APPROPRIATE THAT MOTEL HAD
ISSUES FROM. CODE ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S
MAKING THAT DOLLAR DO MORE. THAN
JUST PROVIDE HOUSING OR JUST
BUILDING A STREETER CHEST IN A
BUILDING A PARK. AND THEN.
PARTNERING BOTH FINANCIALLY AND
WITH THE HOUSING AUTHORITY IN
THE COUNTY FOR ULTIMATELY DOING
A MOTEL CONVERSION AND CREATING
PERM SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WHICH
THEN LINKS EQUALLY. TO THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
EITHER THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IF YOU ARE
SERIOUS THE HOUSING FUNDS IN
RELATIONSHIP TO AND PROVIDING
SERVICES SO AGAIN IT'S REALLY
KIND OF READING THE LINKAGES. OF
THE LOCAL LEVEL ROSE TO THE
COUNTY TO THE SERVICES TO OUR
PARTNERS IN PROVIDERS. TO
ADDRESS AND THE RESIDENTS AND IT
REALLY GETS INTO THAT INTEGRATED
APPROACH.
BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE RESOURCES
BUT AND THEY ALL HAVE A GREAT
PURPOSE.
AND MANY TIMES THOSE RESOURCES
ARE GOING DOWN TO IT EQUALLY
MORE IMPORTANT OF HOW DO YOU
APPLYING THEM TOGETHER TO
ACCOMPLISH THE OBJECTIVE.
AND EQUALLY ONE OF THE THINGS
WHICH IS SECURE COMPETITIVE
FUNDING FOR OUR REGION. HEAT YOU
MENTIONED JOSH CANDELARIA OUR
BOARD IS VERY ACTIVE AND YOU
HAVE SEEN ASKS MANY TIMES IN THE
OFFICES ABOUT LOOKING AT BILLS
LOOKING AT FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES.
LOOKING AT TRYING OF HOW DO WE%
CAPTURE THAT THE FUNDS ARE GOING
TO BE IF BILLS ARE GOING
FORWARD.
HOW DO WE ASSURE THERE'S EQUITY
DISTRIBUTION OF POTENTIAL
REVENUES I'M FOR OUR REGION AND
AND WHAT IT REALLY GETS TO AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT JOSH HAD
ALWAYS IDENTIFIED? IS.
.
IS THAT IT ISN'T SO MUCH THE
BILL THE BILL OBVIOUSLY IS FEAR
OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT TO GETTING
THE MECHANISM IN PLACE. IT IS
THEM BOTH LOCAL STATE AGENCIES
WHO WRITES WRITES THE REGULAR
ACTIONS FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THAT IS CRUCIAL IN
RELATIONSHIP TO BEING INVOLVED
AT THAT LEVEL. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE STATE BECAUSE.
WHETHER ITS STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL.
AS WE HAD DIALOGUE WITH THEM
ABOUT CHANGING CAP AND TRADE
REGULATIONS FOR THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE THEY HAD DENSITIES THAT
WAS ON ECONOMICALLY UNVIABLE FOR
OUR COUNTY AT THE DENSITIES. OR
TALKING WITH EIGHT CD WHO'S NOW
WRITING REGULATIONS ON S. B.
TWO.
IS FOUND REACHING OUT AND
TALKING WITH US AND AND
HOPEFULLY AND RELATIONSHIPS
ABOUT.
HAVING SOME IMPACT ON ON HOW
THOSE REGULATIONS ARE WRITTEN
AND IMPLEMENTED SO THAT THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR.
INVESTMENT ACROSS THE STATE AND
AGAIN FOR OUR COUNTY WE WILL
FIGHT HARD AND TRYING TO CAPTURE
THOSE FUNDS FOR OUR REGION.
BECAUSE WE HAVE GREAT PARTNERS
AND WE HAVE LIKE EVERYWHERE
THERE'S MORE DEMAND THAN THERE
IS SUPPLY.
AND SO THE COOPERATION BOTH AT
THE LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL. IS A
HUGELY IMPORTANT. AND THEN I'M
BRIEFLY GOING TO GO THROUGH WHAT
SUPERVISOR.
GONZALEZ MENTIONED ANTS TO GIVE
YOU A HIGHLIGHT OF. OF AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
BLOOMINGTON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAD DIRECTED THE CBO
ABOUT LOOKING AND INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE COUNTY ON A
CORPORATE IT. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
COUNTY ANA COOPERATED AND WHY WE
LOOKED AT THAT IS.
UNLIKE CITIES HAVING COME FROM
CITIES.
NADA UNDERSTANDING THE BEAUTY
OF WHILE THERE'S A SEWER AND
THERE'S WATER AND THERE'S A
SIDEWALK AND THERE'S A STORM
DRAIN AND I'M GONNA FIND A SITE
TO INFILL. AND COMMIT TO. IT
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO ATTRACT
INVESTMENT IN THE COUNTY
INCORPORATED YOU DON'T HAVE
THOSE THINGS THAT THE COST OF
DOING AFFORDABLE. HOUSING OR
DOING INVESTMENT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND COUNTY
INCORPORATED POCKETS IS EVEN
MORE OF AN ECONOMIC CONSTRAINTS.
WE FOUND THAT. THE BOARD THROUGH
THE CHAMPIONING AB BY SUPERVISOR
GONZALEZ ACTUALLY FUNDED A
SPECIFIC PLAN FOR THE BALLOT
CORRIDOR LOOMING TENNIS TALKED.
BETWEEN THE CITY OF RIALTO IN
THE CITY OF FONTANA. AND THE
PROJECT.
IS PART ON VALLEY CORRIDOR AND
TYPICALLY AS YOU SAW ON THE
WORLD OF REDEVELOPMENT YOU USE
PUBLIC FACILITIES AND HOUSING AS
ECONOMIC REVITALIZATION TOOL FOR
AREAS AND THAT'S HOW. YOU SHOULD
BE INVESTING FUNDS THIS
IDENTIFIES THE MAP.
WHERE THE PROPERTIES ARE
LOCATED WE'RE HOPING EQUALLY TO
RELOCATE A PARK AS PART OF A
THIRD PHASE?
THIS IS A MULTI GENERATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED UNITS INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AND ACTUALLY THE
INTEGRATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT HOUSING.
UNITS WITHIN THE DEVELOPMENT WE
HAD THE LIBRARY AND THERE WAS
OVER SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENT PRETTIES TWO PHASES
SUMMER OF WORKING ON THE THIRD
PHASE. AND ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK EQUALLY THAT'S IMPORTANT
IS PARTNERSHIPS WITH. THE WITH
THE NONTRADITIONAL PARTNERS LIKE
THE SCHOOL.
BECAUSE WE'VE STARTED DIALOGUE
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
THE LIBRARY. AND WE TALK TO THEM
ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE
THEIR RESOURCES ON BOOK BUYS AN
EDUCATION AND EVENTUALLY USING
THE COMPUTER LEARNING CENTER.
THAT GAVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
THE GRAPHIC WAS THAT THE PICTURE
OF WHAT THE LIBRARY WILL BE
INTEGRATED HOUSING ABOVE IT
HELPED US FROM THE ECONOMICS OF
THE PROJECT.
AND THIS GIVES YOU ARE ALWAYS
LIKE ON OUR DEVELOPERS PROVIDE
NICE PICTURES OF AMENITIES BUT
TO ME WHAT IT REALLY GETS IS
ABOUT KIDS.
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
ULTIMATELY LEFT THERE YOU MET
LISA WHO IS ONE OF THE RESIDENTS
AGAIN AT THE NEXT GENERATION OF
SENIOR AND HOUSING? AND IT TAKES
A LOT OF WORK AND IT IS A
COMMUNITY CELEBRATION.
ENDS.
AND I AND I I DO YOU KNOW AND
AGAIN I'M WORKING IN A COUNTY IT
REQUIRES YOU TO WORK WITH SOME
ANY OTHER JURISDICTIONS. AND THE
REQUIRED US TO PARTNER NOT
THROUGH WITH LAUGHED CHO AND THE
CITY OF RIALTO AND THE COUNTY
AND TRYING TO GET THROUGH ALL
THE PROCESSES.
SO WITH FACTS AND THE ONE THING
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT IN
RELATIONSHIP TO BLOOMINGTON FOR
FUTURE POLICY.
IS.
SOMETHING IN TALKING WITH THE
CITY ARE TERRIBLY FOR THE
MEETING IS THERE ARE OR. LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS ARE FUNDS THAT ARE
COMING THROUGH EIGHT CD ANTI
CAC.
AND IT'S TALKING ABOUT TARGETING
INTO HIGH OPPORTUNITY AREAS
AND HIGH AWKWARD TRYING TO GET
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. INTO I'M
HIGHER SOCIAL ECONOMIC
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BETTER SCHOOLS AND BETTER
AMENITIES. BUT THE CONCERN IS
REALLY FINDING A BALANCE BECAUSE
BLOOMINGTON MAY NOT.
YOU HAVE BEEN FOUND THAT BECAUSE
THIS ISN'T A HIGH ECONOMIC HIGH
OPPORTUNITY AREA AND WHAT
EQUALLY IS OF CONCERN IS PASS.
IF THAT'S THE PHILOSOPHY THAT
GOES DOWN INTO THE FOCUS OF HIGH
OPPORTUNITIES THE ONE SOURCE OF
FUNDS THAT STILL AVAILABLE FOR
ECONOMIC REINVESTMENT AND
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
FROM A SOCIAL ECONOMIC
STANDPOINT. YOU'VE JUST
REDIRECTED INTO THE HIGH INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND BLOOMINGTON MAY
NEVER HAPPEN BUILT IF THAT WAS
THE EXISTING PHILOSOPHY AT THE
STATE. SO THAT WAS THE ONE
POLICY THING IN RELATIONSHIP TO
BLOOMINGTON THAT I WANTED TO
BRING TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT I WANT TO JUST TAKE A
MOMENT AND ACKNOWLEDGE WE'VE
BEEN JOINED. BY OUR SENATE
COLLEAGUES SUTTER COUNTY LABOR.
WHO HAS BEEN A GREAT CHAMPION
FOR HOUSING?
AND TACKLING THESE ISSUES I
KNOW OUR COLLEAGUE MISTER
STEINORTH HAS A QUESTION FOR. MS
POINTERS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I I
WANTED TO ASK ABOUT THE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES WITH REGARD TO SB
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S. A
POSSIBLY SOME LOCAL CONSORTIUM
ISSUES REGARDING THE COUNTY THAT
THEY WERE HOPING TO ADDRESS
DURING THE REGULATION PROCESS
COULD YOU EXPAND ON THAT. YES
AND AND THANK YOU COME IN IN SP
TWO IT HAS OBVIOUSLY THE FUNDS
ARE DIRECTED TO GET TO THE LOCAL
CITIES IN THE COUNTY AND IT'S
BASED UPON. WHAT'S IDENTIFIED IN
THE BILL THROUGH THE QUEEN ABOUT
A BLOCK GRANT WHAT HAD USES FOR
THE METRICS PERCY PPG IN ABOUT A
BLOCK GRANT ALLOCATION. FOR ONE
THING THE BILL IS UNCLEAR AND
THAT THE H. CD STAFF.
AS THERE HAS BEEN GREAT AND
OBTAINING DIALOGUE IS WHAT ABOUT
THE CONSORTIUM'S
BECAUSE IN RELATIONSHIP TO OUR
COUNTY. WE HAVE.
BETWEEN TWENTY FOUR CITIES.
AND THE COUNTY OF WHICH. ELEVEN
CITIES GET DIRECT ENTITLEMENT
AND THE REMAINING THIRTEEN
INCLUDING THE COUNTY ARE PART OF
THE COUNTY CONSORTIUM. IF
CONSORTIUMIS NOT PART OF THE
METRICS IN THE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS
THEN ELEVEN OF OUR CITIES WILL
GET A DIRECT ALLOCATION THE BEST
BE TO. THE COUNTY WILL GOTTA A
MODIFIED VERSION AND THEN THE
REMAINING TWELVE CITIES WILL
HAVE TO COMPETE AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL TO SECURE FUNDING FROM S.
B. TO THE WAY THE METHODOLOGY
AS.
AND WE'VE HAD THIS DIALOGUE WITH
EACH CD ROM. AND AND THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP TO THEM AND THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY ARE. WEIGHING IN
RELATIONSHIP TO WHAT ULTIMATELY
THEIR REGULATION BUT SAY
OBVIOUSLY FROM OUR COUNTY YOU
KNOW WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
CONSORTIUM. AND THE WAY THE HEAD
METRICS WORKS TO BE CARRIED OUT
IN THE S. B. TWO ALLOCATION
BECAUSE WE ARE CONCERNED BUT
THEN WE HAVE. A VARIETY OF
CITIES WHO THEN HAVE TO COMPETE
AT THE STATE LEVEL VERSUS
ENSURING THAT THE FUNDS ARE
STAYING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN A MORE DISPERSED.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHEN WE GO
TO OUR NEXT PRESENTATION OF MR
UPON TELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF I MAY
HAVE THE CLICKER DINA.
I IT'S HONORED TO BE BACK BEFORE
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ARAFAT OR
CALL ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
COMMITTEE AT THE INVITATION OF
THE VICE CHAIRMAN. SO THE
REFRIGERATOR THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE SECOND
OPPORTUNITY. I'M IN THE SPIRIT
OF TIME I'M GOING TO ESSENTIALLY
BLOW THROUGH.
THE POWER POINT PRESENTATION I
KIND OF GET TO THE MAIN POINTS
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE YOU
WITH.
BUT THE PROJECT THEY WERE USING
AS A BACKDROP IS WORTHY OF NOTE
FOR A COUPLE REASONS.
ARROWHEAD GROVE IS THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF THE NINETEEN
FORTY THREE ARAB PUBLIC HOUSING
PROJECT.
I TURNED FIFTY TWO UNITS IN
SAMBOR MEDINA.
AND SO THIS IS A PROJECT THAT I
HAD SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AND AT THE
TIME OF THE BEGINNING OF THE
EFFORT TO REVITALIZE IT
REDEVELOPMENT STILL EXISTED.
DURING THE PROCESS OF GETTING
THE ENTITLEMENTS REDEVELOPMENT
WENT AWAY AND THE CITY IS HAMMER
YOU KNOW ENTERED INTO BANKRUPTCY
SO OTHER THAN THAT LITTLE
CHALLENGES PROJECT HAS BEEN NO
PROBLEM AT ALL.
I'M AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
IS THE PROJECT IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN NATIONAL
CORPS THE HOUSING AUTHORITY THE
CITY AND THE COUNTY. AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL THAT HAVE
COME TOGETHER TO BE PART OF THE
PARTNERSHIP IN ORDER TO MOVE IT
FORWARD.
A COUPLE OF INTERESTING JUST
FOOTNOTES ALONG THE WAY HAVING
SAID WHAT I SAID ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF THE DEVELOPMENT
THE FIRST PHASE OF THE PROJECT
WE DID. WAS A FIVE ACRE OFFSITE
PARCEL IN ORDER TO HELP WITH THE
RELOCATION OF RESIDENTS DURING
THE CONSTRUCTION AND DEMOLITION
ON THE PROPERTY.
WE WERE ABLE TO ACQUIRE A FIVE
ACRE PARCEL IN FROM THE TIME WE
GOT SITE CONTROL UNTIL THAT TIME
THE PARCEL WAS FULLY ENTITLED
INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL
APPROVALS. WAS TIED THREE MONTHS
NINETY DAYS.
SO IT CAN BE DONE IN THE SERIOUS
EVER YOU KNOW STOOD UP AND MADE
IT HAPPEN IT'S ANY CITIES THAT
SAY THEY CAN'T GET IT DONE IS
JUST NOT TRUE NINETY DAYS FROM
CONTROL TOLL FULL ENTITLEMENT
INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL EIGHTEEN
MONTHS UNTIL WE WERE FULLY
OCCUPIED CONSTRUCTION COMPLETED.
WE MOVED AYE WE HAVE NOW MOVED
ON SITE WITH THE FIRST PHASE ON
SITE. IN A COUPLE OF THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WERE FOLLOWING
THROUGH IS THAT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS PROJECT IS NOT JUST TO
REPLACE THE HOUSING UNITS IS TO
ADD SOME ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY TRANSFORM THE ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOOD IS A PROJECT.
AND SO A COUPLE OF THE CONCEPTS
THAT WENT ALONG WITH THAT.
ONCE AGAIN I JUST SKIPPING
THROUGH MOST OF THE SLIDES
SO THESE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
WE WERE ABLE TO DO AS PART OF
THIS REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT.
IS NUMBER ONE WE DID A SPECIFIC
PLAN FOR THE ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
BECAUSE THE CITY IS HAMMERED
UNIT NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO IT AND OUR COMMITMENT FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING WAS NOT JUST
READ DEVELOPING THE SITE AND
REPLACING THE HOUSING. BUT
TRANSFORMING THE NEIGHBORHOOD
SAMAEL COUNTY HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED THE LEAST HEALTHY
MAJOR METROPOLITAN COUNTY IN THE
NATION. THE INTERSECTION OF
BASELINE A WATERMAN IS THE LEAST
HEALTHY INTERSECTION IN THE
COUNTY SO WE'RE REDEVELOPING THE
LEAST HEALTHY INTERSECTION IN
THE ENTIRE NATION.
AND THAT'S BASED ON RATIOS OF
FAST FOOD VAPE STORES LIQUOR
STORES MARIJUANA IT'S CENTERED
CENTER AND POVERTY RATES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES INTO
THAT CALCULATION.
AND SO THIS PROJECT IN THE FUNDS
THAT HAVE COME TO THIS PROJECT
ARE NOT JUST GOING TO CREATE
QUALITY HOUSING GREGORY ABLE TO
REVITALIZE THE ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
JUST REAL QUICK AS WITH ALL OF
OUR PROJECTS AND BY THE WAY I'M
THAT PRESIDENCY OF NATIONAL
COMMITTEE RENAISSANCE WHERE THE
LARGEST NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IT NINE THOUSAND
UNITS WERE ALSO IN TEXAS AND
ARKANSAS.
AND WHERE A TYPICAL NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER.
AND SO WE USE EVERY TOOL THAT'S
AVAILABLE ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSTRUCTION WAS SIX PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE HAPPEN TO BE VERY BUSY BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT EVERY
PROJECT IS GETTING TOUGHER
NOTCHES FROM A FINANCING
STANDPOINT BUT FROM A POLITICAL
STANDPOINT. BUT AT LEAST THE
MARGINS ARE GETTING THINNER.
I HAVE A MAYES LISTENING TO ME
THAT WAS ATTACHED.
WHAT FOUR POINTS I WOULD LIKE TO
LEAVE YOU WITH?
IN ORDER FOR YOU TO THINK ABOUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO DO AS AN INDUSTRY AROUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS NOT JUST
BE SITE SPECIFIC IN OUR
ORIENTATION
WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT THE
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD AND HOW WELL
WE DO CAN BE CATALYTIC IN THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND SO THE MORE WE
THINK ABOUT HOUSING AS A PART OF
IN A CATTLE LAST FOR A CATALYST
FOR THE BETTER OFF WE'LL BE.
THE SECOND IS WE CAN'T JUST
FORGOTTEN FOCUS ON HOUSING AS A
IN ISOLATION WE REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOUSING AS PART OF
THE SYSTEM. AND THE MOST EASY TO
EXACT TO TALK ABOUT IT WHAT I
TESTIFIED ABOUT LAST TIME WAS
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN HEALTH
AND HOUSING. AND HOW WOULD A
CRITICAL SOCIAL DETERMINATE OF
HEALTH HOUSING IS AS SILLY WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR THE LAST WEEK I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH AYE AGE PEOPLE
LAST FORTIFIED YEARS. I'M
GETTING HIGH E. H. P. TO LOOK AT
HOUSING AND YOU'LL BE HEARING
FROM THEM LATER TODAY. BUT
ACROSS THE STATE OF WE THINK
ABOUT THE UTILIZATION OF HEALTH
DOLLARS THE RETURN ON THAT
INVESTMENT IS MASSIVE. IF WE
HAVE ADEQUATE HOUSING FOR THE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
THE BEST EXAMPLE IS THE COUNTY
LOS ANGELES PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT CREATED THERE ARE
HOUSING AUTHORITY. THEY ARE WHAT
THEY ARE EXPERIENCING A NET
POSITIVE CASH FLOW THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER HOUSE
PERSON THE COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICES TO A HOMELESS PERSON.
VERSUS THE COST OF PROVIDING
HOUSING OF SERVICES TO SUNDAY'S
ADEQUATELY HOUSE.
AND SO THINKING ABOUT HOUSING AS
PART OF A SYSTEM NOT AS A STAND
ALONE IN EVERY SINGLE PROGRAM
THAT THE STATE TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE THOUGHT
ABOUT HOUSING SO PROP FORTY
SEVEN FOR EXAMPLE. EVERY SINGLE
PERSON BEING RELEASED OR
RELOCATED WHAT'S THE HOUSING
SOLUTION FOR THAT PERSON IS TO
BE A PART OF THE EQUATION
OTHERWISE OUR EXPECTATIONS WELL.
I'M.
PROBABLY NOT BE REALIZED
ONE OF THE CRITICAL THINGS THAT
WE DON'T DEAL WITH DAY WE NEED
TO DO AT EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT. IS IT'S EASY TO
COUNT THE COST OF FEES IT'S EASY
TO COUNT THE HARD COSTS BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO COUNT THE COST OF
TIME THE COSTA PROCESS.
ACOSTA MEDICATIONS THE COST OF
LITIGATION THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE IS ALL OF THOSE SOFT
COSTS ARE ESTIMATES AND ANYWHERE
FROM FIFTY TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT IN THE COST OF
PRODUCING UNITS.
IF WE KNOW THAT UP FRONT THEN WE
CAN MAKE BETTER DECISIONS ABOUT
OKAY WHAT IS THIS OBLIGATION
THAT WE'RE REQUIRING GOING TO
COST THE PROJECT.
AND WE CAN GET INTO THAT IN
WHATEVER LEVEL OF DETAIL YOU
WANT. AND THEN THE LAST POINT
I'D MAKE IS WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON THE SUPPLY SIDE HOW'D
WE PRODUCE MORE HOUSINGMANY OF
OUR PROGRAMS ARE FOCUSING ON THE
DEMAND SIDE. AND EVERYTIME WE
FURTHER FIND THE DEMAND SIDE WE
FURTHER INCREASE THE COST OF
HOUSING AND THAT SHORTAGE OF
HOUSING AS OPPOSED TO FOCUSING
ON THE DEMAND SIDE AND.
GET INTO THAT HAVE WHATEVER
LEVEL OF DETAIL I WAS TOLD I HAD
FIVE MINUTES THAT SIX MINUTES
AND THIRTEEN SECONDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DID
NOTICE THE FINAL MINUTE AND
THIRTEEN SECONDS YEAH SHE HALF.
ARE.
THE SOMEONE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH I'VE
I'VE BEEN TO THE SITE.
I WAS AT THE SIDETO BEFORE WHEN
IT WAS CALLED WATERMAN GARDENS.
AND OF THE TRANSFORMATION
BETWEEN THAT AND THE HOUSING
THAT YOU NOW HAVE PROVIDED TO
THE RESIDENTS IS.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN NIGHT AND
DAY. AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S AN
ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND I I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK THAT
HOUSE TO BE THE WAY IT IS DONE.
WELL WHEN WE LOOK AT INNOVATIVE
IDEAS AND WE'LL BE HEARING FROM
OTHERS SPEAKERS.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY AND NOT JUST ONE.
WHEN WHEN HOUSING UNIT IT HAS TO
BE A COMPLETE A COMPLETE
COMMUNITY.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT I
KNOW IN BLOOMINGTON. THAT THAT
WAS A TRANSFORMATIVE.
AREA AS WELL I I'M SO GLAD LISA
THAT YOU'RE PART OF THAT BECAUSE
THAT TRANSFORM THE VALLEY
BOULEVARD NO WAY THAT.
COULD NEVER HAVE HAPPENED COULD
NEVER HAVE HAPPENED HAD NOT BEEN
FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF
SUPERVISORS JOSIE GONZALEZ ON
THAT. THAT REALLY WAS.
.
TRANCE FORMATION NO.
THANK YOU SO.
I HAVE JUST A COMMENT AND A
QUESTION THE COMMENT.
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS I
HAD A BILL CALLED. HOUSING FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA WHICH WAS
TRYING TO BREAK DOWN SOME THE
SILOS BETWEEN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND THE HOUSING SYSTEM
THE IDEA BEING THAT.
IT IS FAR MORE HUMANE RATHER
THAN LEAVING SOMEONE
CHRONICALLY.
HOMELESS ON THE STREETS AND THEN
TRYING TO ADDRESS HEALTH ISSUES
AFTER THE FACT TO ACTUALLY BUILD
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND PUT A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS IT'S. IT'S
CHEAPER AND ITS FORMER HE MADE
ALL THE BILL WAS INITIALLY
VETOED BUT WITH ACTUALLY THE
SUPPORT OF ALL OF ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATORS HERE. THE GOVERNOR
DID SIGN IT LAST YEAR AND WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT YOU
MENTIONED SOME STATISTICS.
THAT YOU'VE PROVIDED I WOULD
LOVE TO GET THOSE HERE IS WE'RE%
TRYING TO BASICALLY PROVE THE
CASE THAT.
WE CAN USE OUR SCARCE PUBLIC
DOLLARS MUCH BETTER FOR YOU
HOUSE PEOPLE.
TO ADDRESS THEIR CHRONIC HEALTH
ISSUES EARLY OF SOAPS OF THANK
YOU FOR THAT MY QUESTION THOUGH
THAT YOU REFERENCED A TAX
CREDIT.
BEFORE AND YOU MAY KNOW A FEW
YEARS AGO.
ACTUALLY FOR SEVERAL YEARS I
HAD ANOTHER BILL.
WHICH WOULD HAVE FOUGHT
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED THE
STATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX
CREDIT I WANNA THANK.
MISTER STEINORTH FOR A BEEN A
PRINCIPAL COAUTHOR THAT BILL. WE
HAD A HUNDRED EIGHTEEN OUT OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY LEGISLATORS AT
SUPPORT AT THAT.
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED IT.
WE ARE THINKING AT THIS TIME
THAT IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR THAT.
PARTICULAR SENSOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TAX PLANS WHILE THEY
CERTAINLY HAD BENEFITS FOR
CORPORATIONS AND PROBABLY HIGHER
NET WORTH INDIVIDUALS ARE AS YOU
KNOW GOT IT ABOUT A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCING.
A YEAR TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. PATCH THE
HOLE WOULD YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHETHER WE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT ATTEMPT TO. EXPAND THE
FOR THE HOUSING TAX CREDIT HERE
IN OUR STATE.
YEAH A GREAT QUESTION YELL AT
ULTIMATELY IT'S A MATH PROBLEM.
AND SO THAT THAT THE BALANCING
ACT AND AND JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
THE NEXT PHASE OF WATERING
GARDENS IT WHO IS.
PLANNED TO BE A FOUR PERCENT TAX
CREDIT PHASE. IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR CURRENT APPLICATION TO
THE STREET
YOU GROWTH COUNSEL FOR CAP AND
TRADE FUNDING.
WHICH SHOULD BE THE FIRST
SPECIFIC AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT FUNDED IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. SO WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION SUPPORT
AND IT WOULDN'T HURT TO HAVE
SOME THE FROM SAN
CISCO SUPPORTING A PROJECT IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE AFFECT AFFECT
AFFECT OUT IN A TREE LANDING. A.
SO PLEASE LET ME THAT
INFORMATION I GUESS.
YEAH YEAH THE QUESTION THOUGH IS
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THAT
EQUITY VALUE CREATED BY THE
STATE TAX CREDIT AND HOW COULD
THAT BE LAYERED INTO A PROJECT.
WHAT MAKES THE FOUR PERCENT TAX
CREDIT EFFECTIVE AT WATER
REGARDS IS BECAUSE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS BE TIED TO THE FOUR
PERCENT CREDIT? THEY ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IS THE NINE
PERCENT CREDIT IS SO
COMPETITIVE.
AND YOU KNOW SUCH A LIMITED
SUPPLY THAT WORK BECAUSE HE
LOOKING FOR WAYS IS HOW DO WE
MAKE FOUR PERCENT CREDIT DEALS
WORK AND HOW DO WE FUND THOSE
GAPS. ANSWER REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE NUMBERS IN THE STATE TAX
CREDIT BE HAPPY TO HAVE MY TEAM
WORK WITH YOUR TEAM I JUST DOING
SOME POTENTIAL PRO FORMAS. TO
SHOW HOW THOSE NUMBERS WOULD
STACK UP IN A PROJECT AND.
INNOCENTLY MAKE THE CASE FOR
OKAY AT THIS PRICE WITH THIS
BENEFIT THIS IS THEN HOW WOULD
BE ABLE TO FILL A GAP.
HAVE A GREAT I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS
SURLY.
I HAVE A QUESTION AS WELL TO
GIVE STEVE A SHOUT OUT FOR ALL
HIS HELP IN ONTARIO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CENTER.
THAT WITH THAT WHEN WE GO TO OF
MISS ROSA.
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS MARIA RAZA I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY OF THE COUNTY
OF SYNERGY NOTHING YOU FOR
HAVING ME THIS AFTERNOON.
I AM AS A WAY OF BACKGROUND OR
AGENCY THE HOUSING AUTHORITY IS
THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN THE
COUNTIES SERVING NEARLY THIRTEEN
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS.
THROUGH OUR TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
HOUSING AND HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHER PROGRAMS FUNDED THROUGH
THE HAVE US HOUSING. AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AND SOME
OF OUR CHALLENGES ARE THAT
UNLIKE OTHER HEALTH AND. HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS. WE PROVIDE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF AND FAMILIES THAT.
WE ARE AUTHORIZED AND FUNDED
THROUGH HAD. UNFORTUNATELY WE
NEED TO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE.
AND AND THAT IS REFLECTED BY THE
FACT THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND FAMILIES.
ACROSS OUR VARIOUS A WAITING
LIST
HOWEVER THIS IS. FIFTEEN
THOUSAND YES.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THAT'S NOT REPRESENTATIVE AT THE
DEMAND WITHIN OUR COUNTY.
AS.
.
AND MISS AS REVISOR GONZALEZ
MENTIONED THAT AND THE SEVERAL
WAITING LISTS ARE.
OPEN AND SOME ARE CLOSED A AS
AN EXAMPLE OUR LARGEST A WAITING
LIST FOR THE TENANT BASED
VOUCHERS PROGRAM HAS BEEN CLOSED
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN. AS A
RESULT OF THAT DEMAND WE OPENED
IT FOUR AND NINETEEN DAY PERIOD
AND WE RECEIVED OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS FOR THAT
WAITING LIST.
SO AND AS FAMILIES M. HOPEFULLY
MOVE THROUGH VARIOUS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAMS NEW FAMILIES
ARE PULLED FROM THE US WAITING
LESS. AND SO AS A RESULT IT
TAKES MANY YEARS FOR FAMILIES TO
RECEIVE HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
HOWEVER I WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THE HOUSING
CHALLENGES THINKS TO SEVERAL
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THREE THIS
AFTERNOON.
OUR SPECIAL DESIGNATION AS
CALLED MOVING TO WORK AND ALSO
OUR DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS AND OUR
ABILITY TO ESTABLISH NONPROFIT.
SO I'D LIKE TO ELABORATE ON ARE
MOVING TOWARD DESIGNATION OUR
HOUSING AUTHORITY IS ONLY ONE
PERCENT OF HOUSING AUTHORITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE OVER
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED. THAT HAVE A
SPECIAL DESIGNATION BY CONGRESS
FOR HIGH PERFORMING AGENCIES
CALLED MOVING TO WORK.
AND AND WHAT IT ALLOWS US TO DO
IS TO DEVELOP TRANSFORM AND
ESTABLISH LOCAL HOUSING PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES. THAT BEST MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
HERE WITHIN OUR COUNTY.
SO THE NAME OF THAT DESIGNATION
CAN BE A BIT CONFUSING.
AND THAT IS IT NOT.
ONLY LEADS TO AND ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT THROUGH EMPLOYMENT.
BUT AND THE THREE PRIMARY GOALS
ARE TO HELP EACH FAMILIES
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC INDEPENDENCE.
AT TO PROVIDE FAMILIES WITH THE
VARIOUS HOUSING OPTIONS M. IS AN
EXAMPLE OPEN UP HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES. AND.
.
I.
LOOK I AM HIGHER AND INCOME
AREAS AND TO SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THROUGH ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES.
WE HAVE USES DESIGNATION IN A
WIDE VARIETY OF WAYS. TO HELP
FINANCE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
WHEN SUCH EXAMPLES ARROWHEAD
GROW. TO ACQUIRE HOUSING AND OR
ESTABLISH NEW LOCAL PROGRAMS
SUCH AS ARE NO CHILD LEFT AND
SHELTERED PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM.
WAS CREATED TO HOUSE TRULY
HOMELESS FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
AND COULD ONLY BE DONE AS A
RESULT OF OUR MOVING TO WORK
DESIGNATION. THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL THROUGH VARIOUS
AB PARTNERSHIP EFFORTS INCLUDING
THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS.
BE OUR COUNTY'S DEPARTMENT OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
NAME A FEW OF THE PARTNERS.
WE'RE ALSO A DEVELOPER WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED IN EXISTENCE FOR
NEARLY EIGHTY YEARS HOWEVER FOR
THE PAST THIRTY YEARS. WE'VE
ACQUIRED AND DEVELOPED A REAL
ESTATE HELPING US TO INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF NOT ONLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BUT HOUSING
THAT'S AFFORDABLE ALSO FOR LOCAL
WORKERS
TODAY WE HAVE CLOSE TO THREE
THOUSAND AT THESE HOUSING UNITS.
ALSO JUST RECENTLY WE ACQUIRED
AND ARE IN THE PROCESS OF RE
HAVING TO DEVELOPMENT. ONEIN
VICTORVILLE AND ONE HERE IN THE
CITY OF SIMILAR DINO WHICH WILL
SERVE AS THE HOUSING AUTHORITIES
PER FIRST.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS FOR CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHICH COMBINED WILL
HOUSE NEARLY SEVENTY ONE
HOUSEHOLD YES THE FIRST.
AT RESIDENTS FROM BOTH SIDES
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO ON SITE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES THANKS O THE
PARTNERSHIP OF OUR COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
ALSO TO HELP ALLEVIATE THE NEED
FOR RAPID RE HOUSING ISSUES FOR
HOMELESS FAMILIES.
AND TWENTY TO HAN OUR HOUSING
AUTHORITY WAS ONE UP THE FIRST
IN THE COUNTRY TO ESTABLISH AN
AFFILIATE NONPROFIT HE'S. TO
ASSIST IN LOCAL EFFORTS TO HOUSE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
THIS IS ONE OF THREE AFFILIATE
NONPROFITS THAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED.
TO DATE HE'S PROVIDES RAPIDLY
HOUSING SERVICES TWO HUNDRED.
OF HOMELESS FAMILIES AND
VETERANS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY.
WE HAVE ALSO REDEVELOPED OUR TWO
OLDEST PUBLIC HOUSING AT
DEVELOPMENTS ONE AND MENTIONED
BY STEVE ARROWHEAD GROWTH. WHICH
WERE BOTH BUILT IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN FORTIES.
AND SO IN CONCLUSION I WANTED TO
SAY THAT ARE COUNTY WIDE EFFORTS
ARE A SUCCESS.
.
ARE A SUCCESS AS A RESULT OF THE
VARIOUS PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE
HAVE HERE WITHIN THE COUNTY OF
SAN MARTINO. AT PARTNERS IN THIS
COUNTY WORK OUTSIDE OF THEIR
SILENCE AND HELP ADVANCE OUR
COMMON GOALS.
THANKS TO THE CREATIVE AND
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS FROM OUR
VARIOUS COUNTY AND CITY
DEPARTMENT. COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WE ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF OUR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING ME HERE THIS
AFTERNOON.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS I HAVE
JUST TO A COMMENT AND A QUICK
QUESTION SO. I YOU MENTIONED THE
FIRST PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
PROJECT THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
WORKED ON AND DATA. WE ARE
CERTAINLY HEARING AROUND STATE
CALIFORNIA JUST HOW MUCH DEMAND
THERE IS FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN AND OUT TO
THAT AFFECT OUR COMMITTEE WE'VE
INTRODUCED A BILL THIS YEAR. TO
STREAMLINE AND SPEED UP THE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
WE OFTEN HEAR TAKES. YEARS.
TO MOVE THESE PROJECTS FORWARD
AND OUR HOPE IS TO AT LEAST GET
THE ENTITLEMENT IMPROVEMENT
PROCESS DONE WITH A MATTER OF
MONTHS SO WANTED TO MENTION
THAT.
UP GIVEN WHO YOU REPRESENT.
I'VE HEARD AROUND THE STATE
THAT THE CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL.
HIGH DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN QUITE
DIFFICULT ON ON AGENCIES LIKE
YOURS.
THAT THE CUTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED UNDER. THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND.
MISTER CARSON'S LEADERSHIP AS
WELL AS.
THE ELIMINATION OF FAIR HOUSING
RULES AND OTHERS HAVE REALLY HAD
AN IMPACT ON ON LOCAL
AUTHORITIES LIKE YOURS DO YOU
HAVE A PERSPECTIVE ON ON THAT.
HOW'S YOUR.
ARE YOU RECEIVING THE HELP THAT
YOU NEED FROM HOTTER THERE
THINGS THAT THE STATE CAN HELP
OUT WITH IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT PROVIDING THE
HELP THAT THEY HAVE HISTORICALLY
PROVIDED.
THANK YOU THAT IS A GREAT
QUESTION.
THE FUNDING CUTS SPECIFICALLY
TO THE HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER
PROGRAM FUNDED BY HIDE.
WERE EXTREMELY DRAMATIC LAST
YEAR.
I'VE BEEN IN THE HOUSING
INDUSTRY FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
AND THEY WERE THE LARGEST HIGH
AND THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE.
WE AT OUR PROGRAM WAS AS YOU
KNOW THE FEDERAL BUDGET WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW ON MAY FIFTH. OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND ARE FUNDING
CUTS WERE RETROACTIVE TO JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN YES.
SO AND WE HAD TAKEN SOME
PROACTIVE MEASURES M. SUCH AS
I'M NOT PULLING FAMILIES FROM
THE TENANT BASED VOUCHER WAITING
LIST UNFORTUNATELY. I'M THAT PAT
WHAT THEY CUT SIGNIFY TO ARE
COUNTY IS THAT FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY LAST FAMILIES ARE NOW
BEING SERVED.
AND BECAUSE THE CUTS WHERE RETRO
ACTIVE.
WE DID RECOMMEND AND RECEIVE
APPROVAL FROM AS THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO DIP INTO THE
RESERVES FOR THAT PROGRAM. AND
TO ALSO AS STOP PULLING FROM THE
HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER WAITING
LIST AS WELL. AND WE HAVE NOT
POLL SINCE DECEMBER OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND UP WERE WATCHING
THE FEDERAL BUDGET VERY CLOSELY
AND TO DETERMINE IF AND WHEN WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ASSIST MARK
FAMILIES THROUGH THAT PROGRAM.
AND. THAT IS WHY AS WE ARE USING
ARE MOVING TOWARD DESIGNATION.
ON TO ITS FULLEST INTENT OUT WE
ARE ONE OF THE FIRST HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN THE COUNTRY THAT
HAS TERM LIMITS.
AND FOR FAMILIES ASSISTED
THROUGH THE VOUCHER PROGRAM SO
FAMILIES AND HAVE A FIVE YEAR
TERM. AND THE THERE ARE HARDSHIP
EXEMPTIONS OR AS SELF
SUFFICIENCY EFFORTS WE DO HAVE
FAMILIES. THAT ARE GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL COMPLETING A JOB TRAINING
PROGRAM PURSING HOMEOWNER SHED.
AND THAT PROGRAM AND HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL. AND.
WE ARE CONDUCTING A LONG TERM.
LONGITUDINAL STUDY I WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY AND WE HAVE VARIOUS
PARTNERS HAVE CHECKS THE WORK
FORCE AT INVESTMENT BOARD THAT
ARE ASSISTING OUR FAMILIES WITH
THEIR ECONOMIC. EMPOWERMENT
EFFORTS.
THAT IS RIGHT HONOR.
YES FIRST I JUST WANT EXTEND MY
COMPLIMENTS TO THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY OF THAT TREMENDOUS
ASSET.
JUST REGIONALLY AND ALSO FOR MY
OWN EDIFICATION AND AND TRYING
TO REPRESENT HIS VICE CHAIR
HOUSING AND ALSO TO MISS
WEDNESDAY'S. THE EDUCATION I
RECEIVED FROM BUFFY WAS JUST
TREMENDOUS I DO ALSO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU I AM ONE OF MY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THIS YEAR'S
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. IS WERE
RICH GOING TO TRY AND.
DEFINED THE MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING PROJECTS HERE IN SAINT
MEDINA COUNTY AND AND TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THOSE AS A BLENDED WHERE
FORTY PERCENT OF THE UNITS ARE
RESTRICTED TO PERSONS OF LOW
INCOME. SO I LOOK FORWARD TO I
WORKING WITH YOU AGAIN ON ALL.
THINK YOU'RE GONNA PLUG INTO
THIS GUY THINKING THAT.
WITH THAT DATA RECORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS AND WHEN TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
YEAR HAPPEN IS HEARING TODAY
REQUEST OFF BY STORM MISTER CHIU
MUCH AYE YOUR STRUGGLE TO VIDEO
REAL QUICK.
BUT.
ALRIGHT.
THOSE FEW JUST A OF MYSELF THEM
WITH MY KIDS.
THEY KNOW THAT I GOT THEIR BAG
THEM KIDS THEY CAN THAT HIS LOVE
HIM FOR.
THAT MUCH OF A MOMMA'S YOUR.
TO DATE COULD BE RIGHT.
TYPE A CHERRY FOUNDATION IS UP
FAMILY MODEL PROGRAM WE BRING
THE BEST
TO THOSE WHO NEED THEM.
I WOMEN HAVE BEEN
ROBERT TOP.
THERE HOMELESS
CHEER THAT HAVE BEEN
SCHOOL THEY'VE UNDERGONE A WHOLE
LOT OF FROM.
MTBR BY HOUSE THE
REPORTER SERVICES CASE
MANAGEMENT TENDER LOVE AND CARE.
ABOUT AND THAT PROGRAMS THAT
JANUARY SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN FIVE THREE CHILDREN AND
I CAN SEE THAT'S NOT I.
SET THAT'S FORM PAIN THAT'S A.
POOL WHEN I THINK ABOUT SHONDA.
AND THE AMAZING JERRY ISSUES
BEEN ALL CISCO AT TIMES I
FOUNDATION.
MY HEART DISEASE THIS IS
OVERWHELMING.
I DON'T KNOW I TO BE A MOMMY NOW
BEEN ON DRUGS MY KIDS HOLE I'VE.
SO YOU KNOW THE IT TAUGHT ME HOW
TO VIA SOBRE MAMA BE PRESENT AND
THOUGH I.
MMHM MEANS A LIE.
TO HAVE PEOPLE HERE.
WE HAVE MORE WOMEN AND CHILDREN
WHO ARE HOMELESS.
LOS ON THE STREETS UNABLE TO
ACCESS SAFE AND DECENT HOUSING.
THAT'S ALL THE TIME IS NOW.
AS THEY SEE IT IN THE AERO SOBRE
RULE GAVE US A CASH MATCH GREEN
WITH THAT MONEY.
I WAS ABLE TO YOU THREE KNOW
YOUR LIMITS.
OF PERMITS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
I MOVED INTO THE APARTMENT APRIL
FIRST AND THEN I GOT TO SEE MY
KIDS BACK APRIL THIRTEENTH.
THEY LOVE THEIR OWN IT'S A PLACE
FOR THEM TO BE THEMSELVES YOU
KNOW HOW THEIR OWN SPACE.
NOW GET EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO
AS LONG AS I STAINED. GROUNDED
IN A PROGRAM LIKE TIME FOR
CHANGE.
THANK YOU
SUBARU.
THEY GAVE ME A BLOODLINE AGAIN
YOU ACCESS TO A NEW HOPE.
WE TIME FOR CHANCE FOR. IS THE
WAY OF LIFE.
IT'S NOT A JOB.
IT'S CALLED T.. RIGHT THERE'S NO
I IN TEAM.
SEE I WASN'T A CNN HERO WE WILL
SEE IN A HERO.
OR.
MMHM.
.
SO I JUST WANNA SAY THAT.
SO. I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT SO
NOT PUT ON THESE GLASSES I LOOK
AT THE HOUSING ON AFFORDABLE
ISSUE FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THEM MOST OF MY
COLLEAGUES. I LOOK AT IT FROM
THE BOTTOM UP I'M ONE OF THE
ONLY ORGANIZATIONS IN ONLY
EMPIRE DEATH START OUT DOING
EMERGENCY SHELTER AND WENT ALL
THE WAY TO BECOMING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER. BY SOME SHE
TALKS ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE AWAITING THE IT DOES
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE
CHILDREN THAT COULD BE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
OUTSIDE RIGHT NOW. UNABLE TO
ACCESS STATEMENT DECENT HOUSES
SO I SEE THESE PEOPLE BOB BASIS
WE HAVE WOMEN WHO HAVE CHILDREN
WHO ARE ON THE TIME CLOCK TO THE
DEPENDENCY COURT. AND THEY DON'T
HAVE FIVE YEARS TO WAIT UNTIL A
MAKEUP ON THE LIST AID TO GET
THEIR CHILDREN BACK AND SO I HAD
TO CREATE. MORE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES BEEN AFFORDABLE
OUT WITHOUT I HAVE TO CREATE
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A HOME SECTION
THAT I HAVE FOR YOU IS RIGHT NOW
THERE WAS TO SUBSIDIZE. THROUGH
DONATIONS FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSES ON HOW MY OWN
SECTION A PROGRAM GOING THEM ALL
THROUGH THE PORT OF HOUSING
PROGRAM GOING. RIGHT SO AND
WE'RE OPERATING IS SAN BERNIE
COUNTY RED THE SECOND ALL
REQUESTED A CALIFORNIAN I'M
HAPPY TO SAY THAT I'M UP HERE IN
YOUR AREA SAN FRANCISCO IT IT
ALL CLEAN UP ACTUALLY RELOCATED
UP HERE. SO WE HAVE EXPANDED
TYPE OF JAMES BROWN DAY STAND I
HAD OPPORTUNITY TO MINGLE
SUPERVISOR JANE CAN HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY MEET WITH REALLY BEFORE
HE PASSED AWAY. AND SO YOU KNOW
WHAT WE DO IS WORKING FROM THE
BOTTOM UP I'M NEVER GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT I'M NOT MAKING A
FIFTY FIFTY. I
EVERY IN THE SAME HOUSE ACCESS
ME THE
ABILITY TO GIVE.
RIGHT SO BECAUSE I'M ONE
NONPROFIT NOT HALF OF RAIN
FORMER GOVERNMENT I CAN GET
THINGS OUT OF FASTER AND I'M
HAPPY HERE OVER HERE. NOPE
DEVELOPMENT IS NOT MY DAY JOB
STOCK STILL GET MY PAYCHECK PAY
MY BILLS WITH SOMETHING ELSE I
CAN DO PROJECTS A WHOLE LOT
AFFORDABLE ALLOW THE RULING
ALLEVIATE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
IT SOUNDS REALLY GOOD TO CREATE
A SYSTEM OF HOUSING.
SUPERMARKET A GROCERY STORE THE
FREEWAY THE BUSES BUT GUESS WHAT
UP COMING FROM MY HOUSE AND
FIRST APPROACH AND MY WOMEN THE
HOUSING FIRST. I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE THE LIBRARY OPEN BUT I'M NOT
WORKING ON BLACKBERRIES I
WORKING ON HOUSING CARS WE NEED
HOUSING. THE STOCK OF HOUSING
THAT IS NEEDED FOR THESE WOMEN
IS NOT AVAILABLE IS NOT HERE IT
HASN'T BEEN CREATED I LOVE THE
HOUSING PACKAGE DID YOU GUYS DID
A LOT OF BUSINESS TEN PERCENT
SET UP LIKE A LOW INCOME. SOME
WHAT YOU SAYS I WHAT I WANT TO
DO A LOT OF A SAMPLE LOW INCOME
SOMEBODY HAS GOT TO PRIORITIZE
THE DOLLS WHO ARE LEAST ABLE
LEAST ABLE TO ACCESS HOUSES.
RIGHT THEY HAVE TO BECOME A
PRIORITY BECAUSE WE LOOK AT THAT
LITTLE SEVEN YEAR WITH APARTMENT
BUILDING AND THEN THIRTEEN PRIME
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS. EVEN
ABLE TO GIVE TO MARGINAL FORTY
SIX KEY IS BACK FROM BACH THE
CURE BACK WITH THOSE MOMS IN
THOSE LITTLE REAL NEEDS THANK
YOU. BOTH THE SENATOR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BEING ADDED
DAY CAMP FOR COMMENT TODAY JAMES
ARE OF MY DAYS ARE FROM
FOUNDATION BIG SIX.
SIX OUT OF FIVE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES OF
INNOVATIVE MODELS AND GAVE WAS
RESOURCES TO TAKE YOU TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON THE ROLE
BECAUSE IT CAN HELP OUR
CALIFORNIANS. SEE I SEE YOUR SAN
FRANCISCO HOMELESS WOMEN THEY
LOOK JUST LIKE MY SAN FRANCISCO
HOMELESS WOMEN SEE THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE GOT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS OF WOMEN. AND WOMEN OF COLOR
ARE LEAST LIKELY IS ACCESS BILL
SILICON VALLEY JOBS BUT THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO BE LIVING ON THE
MARGINS SOCIETY DOLE LEAST
LIKELY TO BE A PART ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLAN. THAT PLAN FOR
US TO HAVE ALL THESE WAREHOUSES
IN THE IN THE EMPIRE WHAT ALL
THIS LAND THEM LACKEY YOUR NEXT
GENERATION HOUSING
ADVOCATES IN THE MARIN SHIRTS
HERE IN AND ALL THAT THEY ARE
DOING.
I DID HAVE ONE QUESTION SO I
ASKED MY STAFF.
AS WE
IT'S HEARINGS AROUND THE STATE'S
TO GIVE ME THE.
ARTICLES ABOUT THE LOCAL
EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
ONE THING THAT REALLY JUMPED OUT
FROM THE ARTICLES THAT I READ ON
THE PLANE DOWN HERE ROUTES AMBER
MEDINA WAS.
THAT THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS ONE.
THAT.
APPEAR TO BE SO PREDOMINANT IN
YOUR NUMBERS AND.
TO YOU IN ANY OF THE OTHER FOLKS
IS THIS DIFFERENT PERCENT
VERMENTINO WAR DECEMBER TO DO
YOU KNOW. IT.
IT IT BETTER AT IDENTIFYING AND
I'M JUST FROM UNDERSTAND WHY THE
NUMBER SEE
SO I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE. ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN
OTHER REGIONS OR YOU JUST BETTER
AT KNOWING THAT THIS IS A
PROBLEM IDENTIFIED IT AND TRY TO
ADDRESS IT.
I DO HONESTLY AS PART OF
CONTINUE HERE DAY WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS COUNTY A VERY GOOD
JOB ORGANIZING VOLUNTEERS PUT
APPOINT TIME COUNT. BECAUSE
THERE WAS A TIME THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO ACT WE GET REAL NUMBERS
RIGHT NOW TO GET SOME WE
COLLAPSE THEIR PARTNERS THAT'S
COME OUT EARLY IN THE MORNING AT
FIVE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING. AND
WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF COLLECTING THAT
DATA I WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
JOE COMMITTEE OVER THE HILL
PLEASE GET EFFORT. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP THAT COUNT AND SO
THEY ARE HOMELESS WOMEN OUT
THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE CHILDREN
IT'S IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
IT TRYING TO GET THEIR CHILDREN
BACK AS YOU SEE IN THAT VIDEO
SOME OF THE CAME UP WITH OUR KEY
IT AS THOUGH SHE GOT HOUSING
WITHIN TWO WEEKS AGO OUR KIDS
BACK.
RIGHT THEY GOT THE CLOCK HIDDEN
RAN OUT AND SO YOU KNOW THE
WOMEN ARE OUT THERE AND WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THIS FROM WHAT GENDER
PERSPECTIVE. AND WHAT'S HAPPENED
A WOMEN AND WOMEN GIRLS IN THIS
COUNTY AND HAVE A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SAFE THE
PUCK APOSTATE HOUSES WE HAVE
BEEN HERE ARE PROVIDED FROM
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THINGS TO
REALIZE ABOUT SAMMY
ACCOUNT.
AS WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE IN THE AREA.
HAS SEX TRAFFICKING THE SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN.
BECAUSE WHERE THE CROSSROADS SO
EITHER THEY'RE COMING DOWN NORTH
OR SOUTH THEY'RE COMING FROM THE
EAST TO THE WEST FOR COMING OUT
OF LA AND SO THIS IS AS WE ARE
THE SHIPPING AND AND A
MANUFACTURING HUB. ROUTES OF THE
HUB THE TRAFFICKING OF MOSTLY
WOMEN. AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
TO THAT HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT
IS.
THAT I THINK APPROPRIATELY THE
G. DE CRIMINALIZATION OF THAT
UNDER AGE SEX TRAFFICKERS.
HOWEVER WHAT THEY DID WAS IT
TOOK AWAY THE OPPORTUNITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MOVE THEM INTO A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT. AND SO NOW
WHEN THEY'RE THEY'RE ESSENTIALLY
RELEASED WITHOUT ANY PLACE TO
GO.
AND SO THERE'S A GAP IN THEIR
THINKING ABOUT THE SYSTEM.
ENFORCEMENT IDENTIFIES UNDER AGE
WOMEN IN THE SEX TRAFFIC
BUSINESS WHEN THEY CAN'T
INTERVENE AND THEY HAVE NO PLACE
FOR THEM TO GO? AND SO WE ARE
THE CROSSROADS OF THAT IN
CHAMBER DINO COUNTY AND SO THAT
MADE FURTHER EXACERBATE THE
HOMELESS. ASPECT OF WOMEN WITHIN
THE COUNTY.
IT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I ALSO JUST WANT TO
ALSO THANK GOD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ELOISE.
FOR A CO AUTHORED A BILL THAT
WE HAVE THE TWO OF US HAVE THIS
YEAR TO ADDRESS THE PLIGHT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS WHO
HAPPENED TO BE TENANTS.
BOB BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN THE
SITUATION AROUND THAT THE STATE
WHERE OF YOUR TALENT AND YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
A PARTICULAR HOME.
THE FACT THAT COPS ARE CALLED TO
YOUR HOUSE COULD BE USED BY THE
LANDLORD AS.
BASIS TO ADDICT YOU AND WE WANT
TO CHANGE THOSE RULES SO THAT IS
NOT THE CASE SO I THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT PERSPECTIVE AND NOW
I KNOW WHY.
LUIS YOU ARE SO PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE.
WITH THAT BACK TO YOU.
YOU HEAR FROM SO MANY BE
ADVOCATES HERE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU DELAY YOU WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING I'M AS I'M WAS
MENTIONED DOCTOR BUT HE'S
ACTUALLY HERE WE CAN AVE HIM
AND PROVIDE TO YOU SOME WRITTEN
DOCUMENTATION BECAUSE HE DOES
FOLLOW THE ONE IN FOUR WOMEN
ISSUES WHICH. AND TO GIVE YOU
SOME PERSPECTIVE SO MAKE SURE IT
HAPPENS SEND YOU SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IN RELATIONSHIP TO
OUR COUNTY AS RELATES TO THE
STATE.
THANK YOU LESTER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ON THIS PANEL ONE JUST
THANK THIS PANEL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR WORDS AND
EXPERTISE SO FEEL FREE TO SEND
US MORE INFORMATION BASED ON THE
CONVERSATION. I'D LIKE TO BUY UP
THE FINAL PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE THREE PANELISTS.
AND THIS IS A PANEL ON
HOMELESSNESS ON THE AVERAGING.
RESOURCES LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS WE
HAVE FROM THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENT FOR SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. THE ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO SONYA
THOMAS.
DOCTOR JOE COLLETTI WHO IS THE
CEO OF URBAN INITIATIVES
AND DR JENNIFER SALES THE CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER OF INLAND
EMPIRE.
HEALTH.
WELCOME.
NOW WHEN WE START.
WITH THIS THOMAS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CHIU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATOR
LEYVA.
AS THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FREE HUMAN SERVICES
WHICH ENCOMPASSES OUR DEPARTMENT
OF BE CAREFUL HOUSE WITH SERVICE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. VETERAN AFFAIRS
TRANSITIONAL SURFACED APARTMENTS
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES.
PUBLIC HEALTH AGING ADULT
SERVICES CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES
AND PRESCHOOL SERVICES. MANY OF
OUR CLIENTS ARE IN DIRE NEED OF
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS.
SO IT'S A PLEASURE THIS
AFTERNOON TO SPEAK WITH YOU ON
HOUSE EVERYDAY NO COUNTY HAS
BEEN ABLE TO LEVERAGE LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL RESOURCES.
I'M SO HONORED IN MY HEART
ACTUALLY.
IS.
BEATING OUTSIDE MY CHEST BECAUSE
I THINK YOU GOT A SENSE OF HOW
WE HAVE BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL AND
CREATIVE I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
PREVIOUS PANELS YOU SAW. THE
INTELLIGENCE THE.
CONFIDENCE THAT PASSION AND THAT
ALLOWED US TO BE ABLE TO BE AS
SUCCESSFUL AS WE HAVE HERE AND
SALMON A DINO.
SO THROUGH THE PROGRESSIVE
LEADERSHIP AND POLITICAL WILL OF
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN OUR C. O.. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO FOCUS A VIEWPOINT ON.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THAT ALLOWS
US TO ADDRESS THAT CUTE NEEDS TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES TO
REMAIN STABLE IN THEIR HOMES. SO
IF WHETHER YOU ARE THIS
TRANSITIONAL ASSISTANCE
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR YOU'RE THE
DIRECTOR OF AGING ADULT SERVICE
THIS YEAR DIRECTOR OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
YOU ARE APPLYING.
YOUR RESOURCES IN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ARE TOWARD.
AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS TO SUSTAIN THEM IN
THEIR HOME.
AS YOU HEARD FROM ONE OF THE
PANELISTS TODAY THERE'S STILL A
UNIQUE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOCUS ON CERTAIN TARGET
POPULATIONS THAT HAVEN'T
PREVIOUSLY BEEN THE FOCUS IN THE
PAST. WE HAVE SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS AS IT WAS PRESS TO
HAVE MENTAL ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER WE HAVE LOTS OF
SERVICES FOR VETERANS BUT
THERE'S A UNIQUE AS YOU.
MENTIONED CHAIRMAN CHIU
REGARDING.
THEY NEED TO FOCUS ON
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN.
AHMED ALSO OUR SENIOR POPULATION
THAT IS CONTINUOUSLY GROWING AND
THEIR ART DEDICATED RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESS ISSUES OF
OUR SENIORS.
SO ONE WAY THAT YOU CAN ASSIST
US IS TO ENSURE THAT SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AREADEQUATELY FUNDED
HELP US. OR MAINTAIN OUR
SERVICES TO HOMELESS POPULATION
TO SECURE THE MENTAL HEALTH
pSERVICES ACT IT IS A PROP
SIXTY.
THREE FUNDED.
THROUGH.
A TAX INITIATIVE AND AS WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AS YOU SAW IN
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
INITIATIVE. THERE'S ALL OF THEM
CALLS UPON THEIR RESOURCES THAT
ARE PROVIDED FOR IMAGES SAY BUT
IF THOSE FUNDS CONTINUE TO BE
DIVERTED OR DEPLETED WHO HAVE
LEFT FUNDS TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE A
SUPPORT OF SERVICES. THAT ARE
SO.
GREATLY NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR HOME.
ANOTHER FOCUS IS TO CONTINUE ON
PROBABLY REDUCTION AND FAMILY
STABILIZATION TO PROMOTE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY PROVIDING
INSIGHT THAT I THINK PUBLIC
HOUSING. AS ONE OF THE.
THOMAS MAJID EARLIER TODAY WE
HAVE A LOT OF OF PROGRAMS THAT
ARE. DESIGNED BASED ON THE
PRIVATE MARKETS WHERE WE
PROVIDING RENT SUBSIDIES I WOULD
ENCOURAGE US TO CONTINUE TO
DIVERSIFY AS MS CARTER MENTIONED
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON.
PROVIDING OTHER LEVELS OF.
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS WITH THE
COUNTIES COUNTY WIDE. VISION WE
HAVE A HOUSING ELEMENT ONE OF
OUR PRIORITIES HERE IS TO
PROMOTE RETHINKING. OF
INCENTIVES FOR CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS SO WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO NOT ONLY
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THOSE
SERVICES THAT ALLOW US TO HAVE.
A PERMIT SUPPORT OF VOUCHERS BUT
ALSO LOOK AT OTHER ON HOUSING
CONSTRUCTS.
SO. IN THE THICK OF TIME I WILL.
BRIEF MY PRESENTATION SO THAT
YOU CAN HEAR.
FROM SOME OF OUR OTHER SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS AND COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERS AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
NEEDS OF AN BENITO COUNTY AND
YOUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY.
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR COLLETTI.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AGAIN MY NAME IS JOE COLLETTI
WITH URBAN INITIATIVES AND
BEFORE I BEGIN MY PRESENTATION I
DO WANT TO.
IT'S LIKE A LITTLE QUICKER GOING
TO DO THE JOB.
FORWARDING MY AND.
WHAT AFFAIRS?
SO WHILE THAT'S HAPPENING I DO I
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT ONE IN FOUR
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS AND WOMEN
HERE IN A IN A COUNTY IN THAT.
THE THAT
THE PERCENTAGE. OF.
OF WOMEN THAT MAKE UP THE
HOMELESS POPULATION HERE IN THE
COUNTY IS AS WE'VE BEEN SAYING
ONE OF ONE FOR TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. THAT'S BEEN UP.
.
A PERCENTAGE THAT IS VERY
SIMILAR TO OTHER NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES THAT WE HAVE SEEN. AND
THE ONE THING THAT I FEEL THAT
IT WOULD BE VERY REMISS.
AYE IF I DIDN'T MENTION WITHIN
THIS CONTEXT BECAUSE. AT THE END
OF WHAT THEY SAID THAT WILL SEND
YOU THE DATA ON THAT WE HAVE.
BUT DO WANT TO JUST TAKE A QUICK
MOMENT JUST TO SAY THAT TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE.
IS A MAJOR. MAJOR NEED HERE WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HOMELESS WOMEN.
YOU KNOW THE THE ISSUES ARE
COMPOUNDED.
YOU IN SUCH A WAY THAT AGAIN
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE.
YOU'LL BE UP IS A SIGN AT THE
TRAINING THAT SHOULD BE
INVOLVED.
YOU KNOW THE CASE MANAGERS
EXTRATERRESTRIAL.
DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT.
THE MOMENT SO BY WAY OF MY
PRESENTATION.
I DO WANT TO FOCUS ON FIVE.
HOW COLUMN SUGGESTIONS AT THIS
POINT?
THAT COME OUT OF OUR EXPERIENCE
HERE IN THE COUNTY.
AND THAT IS THIS THE FIRST ONE.
IS THAT YES YOU SEE A.
TABLE. OF OUR HOMELESS COUNT
DATA FOR THE PAST.
FOR YEARS.
AND.
AS YOU KNOW OFTEN.
THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASING
AMOUNT OF ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
BILLS THAT ARE.
TYING THE FUNDING TO A HOMELESS
COUNT.
IT'S GENERALLY THE MOST CURRENT
HOMELESS COUNT.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT LIKE WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE IN IN IN THE
COUNTY. OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS
YOU CAN SEE THAT. THERE HAD BEEN
DECREASES.
YOU KNOW MEANING THAT THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE.
IS GIVING EVIDENCE THAT THE JOB.
IT'S BEING DONE.
AND IF YOU JUST HIGH.
FUNDING TO A NUMBER.
THAT'S PERHAPS THE LARGEST
NUMBER YOU KNOW WITHIN A GIVEN
COUNTY.
THEN WHAT ARE YOU DOING.
ARE YOU FUNDING.
YOU KNOW A A A COUNTY
THAT HAS AN INCREASING AMOUNT.
OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND OR ARE YOU FUNDING A COUNTY
THAT HAS THE DECREASING.
AMOUNT HISTORICALLY YOU PROBABLY
KNOW THAT.
THERE USE TO BE A TIME WHERE.
IT WAS JUST.
PURELY YOU KNOW THAT THE PROBLEM
IS GETTING WORSE THE NUMBERS ARE
GETTING MORE GIVE US MORE MONEY
GIVE US MORE MONEY GIVE US MORE
MONEY AS WE GOT MORE PERFORMANCE
CONSCIOUS AND MORE PERFORMANCE
BASED.
NO THERE'S BEEN A SHIFT THEIR
ABOUT FUNDING BEING TIED TO.
PERFORMANCE AND THUS A DECREASE
THEN NUMBER SO I WOULD SAY THAT.
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT HOW THE
HOMELESS COUNT THAT IS BEING
USED PERHAPS.
WE CAN DO SOMETHING MORE WITH
THAT THE JUST LOOK AT A ONE A
NUMBER FOR A. THE MOST CURRENT
YEAR AND PERHAPS EVEN DO A
COMPARISON.
SO.
WITH THAT I WON A NOTE WITH MY
SON A SECOND SUGGESTION.
IN MATTERS THAT READ A POINT NOW
WHERE WE'RE NO LONGER USING
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION TO
UNDERSTAND HOMELESSNESS I CAN
REMEMBER THOSE DATES.
YOU KNOW AND AND BASICALLY ONE
PERSON WE GET UP AND SAY WELL
THE FASTEST GROWING HOMELESS
POPULATION IS.
YOU KNOW THIS GROUP AND THE
OTHER ONE WHICH A NARROW AT THIS
GROUP AND AND AND THAT TYPE OF A
THING SO NOW WE HAVE DATA YOU
KNOW PARTICULARLY OVER THE LAST.
FIFTEEN YEARS OR SO AND THOSE
SOURCES OF DATA ARE.
THE HOMELESS COUNT.
THE HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
AFFIRMATION SYSTEM H. MY S. IN
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM
WELL.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT.
THE POINT TIME COUNTY THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT THAT IN THE
AND THE USE OF IT.
BUT. IN THAT'S BEING MORE
EMBEDDED INTO.
YOUR LEGISLATION HOWEVER.
HMIS IS NOT.
THAT'S RARELY LOOKED AT IN TERMS
OF ABOUT AT LEAST WHAT I READ
THROUGH THE VARIOUS BILLS IS
IT'S RARELY MENTION.
AND YET.
IT'S A MORE COMPREHENSIVE.
IN A MORE ROBUST
THE AND A SYSTEM.
THEN THE POINT CONCURRENT.
AND HERE IN THE COUNTY.
HAS A VERY ROBUST.
MRS.
WHERE THE USE OF AGE MY S. IS
BEING USED?
AND A LOT OF WAYS THERE'S BEEN
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS TOWARDS.
VETERANS GETTING VETERANS OFF
THE STREETS AND THAT.
LARGELY THROUGH.
THE USE OF HMIS DATA IN
YOU PROBABLY KNOW OF A OF A BY
NAME LIST.
AND HOW THAT'S BEING USED. AND
THE SIESTA COORDINATED ENTRY
SYSTEM.
GENERALLY IS EMBEDDED IN THE TO
MY S..
SO IF YOU'RE GONNA FOCUS MORE
AND THAT'S MY SUGGESTION TO YOU
IS THAT.
DO WHAT'S BEING DONE HERE YOU
KNOW ENCOURAGE.
OTHERS TO USE HMIS.
AND PERHAPS EVEN EMBEDDED INTO
LEGISLATION THAT YOU'RE
BEGINNING TO DO WITH THE POINT
TEN COUNT.
DOCTOR BEFORE YOU MOVE OFF THIS
POINT I JUST WANNA MATCH MY
COLLEAGUES ARE WE DO HAVE A BILL
THAT'S ACTUALLY PROPOSING THAT
WE DO EXACTLY THAT THE CROWDS
ACTUALLY BILL THAT.
LISA HAD SUGGESTED THAT.
THAT WE AUTHORED IT'S.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE OUGHT
TO YOUR POINT. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS COUNTY CITIES OVER
THE LAST.
TEN OR SO YEARS HAVE STARTED TO
TRACK THIS INFORMATION BUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
UNLIKE OTHER STATES AND SO. UP
SO I AM PROPOSING THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DO WERE STARTING
THIS CONVERSATION WE HAVE NOT
EVEN HAD A FIRST HEARING ON THIS
TOPIC BUT. I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU
TO SEND ME INFORMATION THAT WHAT
YOU JUST SAID YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AND WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT WE
MAY.
WE MAY DRAG YOU BACK UP
SACRAMENTO TO TESTIFY AGAIN ON
THAT I SEE IT WE HAD TO DO THIS
ABBY ABBY TO COME AND I WOULD.
COME A LITTLE BIT MORE PREPARED
ABOUT THAT BUT MY LIMITED
UNDERSTANDING OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY ONE IS THAT.
IT FOCUSING MORE ON A STATEWIDE
DATABASE
RIGHT.
AND SO.
AND AND I KNOW THAT THERE WAS AN
ATTEMPT AT A WHAT FIVE OR SIX
YOU WHATEVER WAS TO KIND OF DO
THAT FOR WHATEVER REASON IT
DIDN'T WORK OUT. IT HOPEFULLY
THIS TIME IT IS GOING TO WORK
OUT. BUT ONCE YOU HAVE THAT
DATABASE.
THAT LARGE THAT IS.
STATE DATABASE SYSTEM YOU KNOW
WILL THAT DATA THEN BE AVAILABLE
TO A GIVEN COUNTY IN EACH IN
EACH OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
I MEAN I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE.
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW THE USES OF
IT OTHERWISE YOU CAN HAVE ALL
THIS WONDERFUL STATEWIDE DATA.
AMERICAN IMAGINE ONCE IT
HOPEFULLY THE BILL PASSES
EVERYTHING YOU KNOW EVERYTHING
HAPPENS.
AND THOUGH YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL.
DATABASE FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
BUT.
COUNTIES WHEN INDEED THE
BREAKDOWN.
RELEASE WOULD BE HOPEFUL AT ONE
END AND TO THAT POINT YOUR APPS
TO RIGHT ITSELF.
I THINK THE GOAL OVER TIME IS TO
FIGURE OUT IF ALL CITIES ARE ARE
ARE ARE GETTING THIS INFORMATION
COUNTIES ARE GETTING THIS
INFORMATION.
WE CAN THEN HELP REGION'S
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
PATTERNS OF HOMELESS MIGRATION.
AND AND MOVEMENT AND AND
SERVICES ARE BEING PROVIDED.
ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE OF THE STATE HAS
HISTORICALLY DONE A VERY GOOD
BAD JOB OF THE SORT OF LARGER.
IT DATA PROJECTS AND BEING ABLE
TO INTEGRATE SUCCESSFULLY
SEAMLESSLY WITH LOCALS BUT THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD BE MY HOPE.
BUT BUT TO IT'S A POINT WELL
TAKEN SOMETHING THAT THAT WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT.
SO.
THIRTY JUSTIN FOCUSES ON
DETERMINING NEED.
AND WHEN THE.
WHEN HARD INTRODUCED THE.
HOW ARE THEY ACT CONTINUE OF
CARE PROGRAM INTERIM RULE? BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
RIGHT.
BOB THAT WAS A SHIFT FOR
EVERYBODY MATCHES HERE IN THE
COUNTY BUT EVERYWHERE ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES ALL FOUR HUNDRED
PLUS.
TEAMS OF CARE NOW HAD THE COUNTY
GET WITH THE WITH THE INTERIM
RULE. AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS VERY.
HARD TO ADJUST TO.
BUT.
HERE IN THE COUNTY QUICKLY
ADJUSTED TO BUT THE ONE THING
THAT WAS HARD TO ADJUST TO WAS.
THAT HAVE JUST THE V. D. SYDNEY
THE.
THE DECISION MAKERS WERE
PRIMARILY THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
IF YOU TURN BACK THE CLOCK AND
WENT TO A. HOMELESS COALITION
MEETING IN A GIVEN.
COUNTY OR SO TEN YEARS AGO OR
SO.
IT WAS DOMINATED BY HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE. AND DOING A LOT
OF GREAT WORK.
BUT NOBODY ELSE WOULD BE AT THE
TABLE.
IF YOU WENT TO THAT MEETING.
YOU KNOW YOU B. WONDERING WHY MY
THEIR AND I'M NOT SURE. BUT
NEVER COMING BACK BECAUSE HE GOT
ALL THE SERVICE BY PROVIDERS
TALKING ABOUT THEIR THINGS IN
THEIR LANGUAGE.
AND IT WAS VERY HELPFUL FOR THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
INTERIM RULE IS THAT.
THERE WAS A CHANGE
AND THAT THE INTERIM RULE IS NOW
ENCOURAGING BUSINESSES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT UNIVERSITY
REPRESENTATIVES YOU KNOW TO
BECOME.
MORE INCREASINGLY VISIBLE AN
ACTIVE.
AND SO HERE AND.
THERE'S THE INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS CHAIRED
BY.
PROVIDER GONZALEZ.
AND.
.
SHE ARE AND THEN SO BE IT YOU IF
YOU WERE AT ONE OF THOSE
MEETINGS YOU WOULD SEE THAT
THERE'S A LARGE REPRESENTATION
BY.
BEYOND THE SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND SO.
IT
THERE WAS AN INITIAL FEAR.
BECAUSE
I WAS INVOLVED IN IN.
IN IN A LOT OF THIS EARLY ON.
THAT WHAT YOU KNOW YOU BRING
THESE FOLKS AND YOU KNOW THESE
BUSINESS FOLKS OR YOU KNOW EVEN
IF SOMEBODY FROM.
UNIVERSITY THEN YOU KNOW
CORPORATION OR SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW WOULD HAVE ANAL ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS KNOWS IT WAS HIS
FEAR OF THIS LEARNING CURVE.
YOU KNOW LIKE WITH YOU.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN BUT GUESS WHAT
YOU KNOW YOU MAY HAVE TAKEN A
LITTLE WHILE? BUT LIKE HERE IN
THE COUNTY IS A VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE WE HAVE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT FOLKS.
THAT PERHAPS MOST OF THEM RUN
LEARNING CURVE.
AND THEY GOT WITH THE PROGRAM.
THEY VERY ARTICULATE ABOUT THE
ISSUES.
VERY MUCH UNDERSTANDING SO THAT
INITIAL FEAR.
IS NOT TRUE SO TO WHATEVER
DEGREE.
YOU CAN BET SOMETHING LIKE THIS
INTO LEGISLATION.
PLEASE DO.
PLEASE DO IT OF HIS A SAID THE
INITIAL FINDINGS IN THE
BEGINNING OF SOMETHING IS JUST
THAT. I THINK THAT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY.
IT WOULD GIVE.
YOU KNOW COUNTIES BY COUNTIES I
MEAN YOU KNOW NOT JUST A COUNTY
ITSELF BUT ALL OF ITS PARTNERS
YOU KNOW SOMETHING MORE TO POINT
TO. AND THE COURAGE OF OTHERS TO
BE PART OF.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE TO WHATEVER
DEGREE YOU CAN EMBED THAT INTO
LEGISLATION.
PLEASE DO THAT.
THEN.
.
THE.
FOR THINK THAT ONE OF FIVE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WAS HISTORICAL PARTNERSHIPS.
BECAUSE.
BRINGING THE COUNTY TOGETHER
WHICH CITY OFFICIALS TO DISCUSS
HOMELESSNESS.
AS A START BUT IT IT IT'S.
NOT ENOUGH.
IT MAY NOT ENOUGH.
AND THEY HAVE CITY OFFICIALS
NEED TO BE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
ANY HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE COUNTY.
OKAY WE NEED CITY OFFICIALS.
NEED TO BE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THAT BUT.
WHAT OFTEN HAPPENS WHEN YOU CAN
LOOK AT? THE HOMELESS COUNT DATA
HERE.
IS THAT.
WHEN YOU GO TO A CITY COUNCIL
MEETING.
AND
THE ADVENTURES SEVERAL RIGHT YOU
HAVE THE TWENTY FOUR CITIES
HERE.
YOU DON'T HAVE
SAME CONVERSATIONS AS YOU DO AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL.
YOU CAN JUST.
A FEW OF THE CITY'S YES.
BUT MOST NO BY THAT I MEAN.
YOU KNOW THAT THE
YET WHAT IS HOUSING FIRST RAPID
RE HOUSING OR COORDINATED
ENTRIES.
ALL THESE DIFFERENT THINGS YOU
KNOW AND SO.
A LOT OF CITIES DON'T HAVE.
THE COUNCIL MEMBERS.
I DON'T HAVE THE BENEFIT OF ALL
THAT.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS THAT COULD
HELP.
THEM.
ACHIEVE THE BENEFIT OF ALL OF
THAT. IS TAKING HOMELESS COUNT
DATA AND SO WHAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF THE HERE. IS A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NUMBERS FOR THE
COLONY.
AND OUT OF THE TWENTY FOUR
CITIES YOU HAVE JUSTICE.
SIX THAT ARE LISTED HERE THOSE
WITH THE LARGEST HOMELESS
POPULATION.
AND THEY MAKE UP FIFTY EIGHT
PERCENT.
OF.
BALL THE TOTAL HOMELESS
POPULATION SO I MEAN EVEN WHEN
YOU'RE FOCUSING ON CITIES.
YOU'VE ENTIRE GET AYE HANDFUL OF
CITIES AND BY WAY OF WHICH MAY
BE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF YOUR
CITIES BUT THEY'RE REPRESENTING
MORE THAN FIFTY PERCENT OF YOUR
HOMELESS POPULATION. AND SO THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALL OF THAT.
I WANT TO UNDERLINE IS LIKE
TAKING ONTARIO. IS AN EXAMPLE.
I'M OFTEN WHEN YOU HEAR
SOMETHING LIKE WELL JUST GONNA
PUT BACK FOR A MOMENT AND JUST
SAY WELL WE HAVE EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX HOMELESS
PERSONS RIGHT.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX HOMELESS PERSONS LET'S
AND HOMELESSNESS FOR ALL
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX.
COMES ACROSS AS PRETTY DAUNTING
RIGHT.
BUT HOWEVER WHEN YOU'RE BREAKING
THE DATA DOWN.
SO LIKE HERE YOU HAVE FOR THE
CITY ONTARIO WAS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS FIFTY
NINE PERSONS WERE COUNTED HAS ON
SHELTERED.
YOU SELL ONE YOU KNOW STRIP
TENURE THE CITY COUNCIL AUTUMN
YOU KNOW AND AND WE'RE HITTING
YOU WITH THIS THIS INFORMATION
WELL. YOU KNOW WE COME TO YOU
AND SAY THERE'S EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX
YOUR PERCENT HOMES IN THE COUNTY
FIRST THING PROBABLY ONE IS
WILLING TO DO IT ALL THIS COUNTY
INFORMATION. GIVE ME CITY
INFORMATION
SO WE START FEELING OF THIS.
CITY INFORMATION THAN SOMETHING
LIKE A DAUNTING EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX NUMBER MAY. OT COME
ACROSS SO DAUNTING ONCE WE BREAK
IT DOWN FOR YOU AND SAY WELL YOU
KNOW IN CITY OF ONTARIO.
WAS FIFTY NINE PERSONS
RECOUNTED ISN'T SHELTERED
BY THE WAY.
NINETEEN OR WOMEN.
ALLISON YOU'RE THINKING WELL YOU
KNOW.
CAN'T WE KNOW THOSE NINETEEN
WOMEN YOU KNOW KELLY EN THAT FOR
THOSE NINETEEN WOMEN OKAY
EIGHTEENTH EIGHTEEN.
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
WITH O'CONNELL COUNTY IS PRETTY
DAUNTING.
BUT YOU KNOW THERE WAS SIX
VETERANS.
I KNOW THE FIFTEEN.
FOR YOU.
AGE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY. CAN'T WE
GET THOSE FOR YOU.
ONE SENIOR AGE SIX.
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE USING THE
DATA IN SUCH A WAY.
THAT.
FOLLOW SAID IN ENDING
HOMELESSNESS AND SEEM TO BE SUCH
A.
I OUT OF OUT OF REACH THINK WE
COULD ACTUALLY BEGIN.
TO DO THAT.
AND SO.
.
THE LAST.
SUGGESTION THAT I HAVE FOCUSES
ON COORDINATING AND
CONCENTRATING.
I RESOURCES.
AND SO HERE IN THE COUNTY. IN IN
A LOT OF OTHER PLACES LEVERAGING
FEDERAL FUNDS STATE FUNDS AND
COUNTY FUNDS.
IT'S BEEN HISTORICALLY DONE
PRETTY WELL YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
HERE.
AND THEN AND ELSEWHERE. BUT
OFTEN CITY FUNDS.
YOU KNOW OUR YOU NO PARTICULATES
ARE CTG DOLLARS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THEY'RE NOT AS OFTEN TIED TO
THE ABOVE FUNDING.
YOU NO AND SO. ARE IN A PRIVATE
FUNDS
OFTEN ARE TIGHT IT'S JUST
GENERALLY.
YOU HAVE.
.
YOU DON'T NOT PROFITS.
WRITING GRANT APPLICATIONS
BEING VERY SUCCESSFUL UP WITH
THE PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS.
WANT THE FUNDS SERVE NONPROFITS
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO CONTINUE
THAT WORK. HERE IN THE COUNTY
AND PRIVATE FUNDS THOUGH YOU
HAVE YOU ALREADY HEARD.
SOMEWHAT ABOUT THE AYE HP AND
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR MORE ABOUT IT
IN JUST. A MOMENT OF THE
PARTNERSHIP THERE AND HOW THOSE
THESE PRIVATE HEALTH CARE
DOLLARS ARE BEING LEVERAGED YOU
KNOW. BUT.
WHAT I'M SAYING TO YOU BY WAY OF
THIS SUGGESTION IS TO TO
WHATEVER YOU COULD ENCOURAGE
WHATEVER YOU CAN DO THAT
ENCOURAGES CITIES?
THE TIGHTER FUNDING AND I KNOW
SOME OF THAT'S BEING DONE IN
SOME OF THE ASSEMBLY BILLS WHERE
YOU'RE WHERE THE COUNTIES WHERE
YOU'RE GIVING MONEY THE COUNTIES
BUT THEN YOU'RE BEING TIED TO
THE CITY'S.
THAT'S A BIG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN THE MORE YOU CAN
DO.
IN REGARDS TO THAT THE BETTER.
GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH THAT WHEN WE GO TO OUR
FINAL PRESENTATION.
DOCTOR SEUSS.
RIGHT.
SO THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
VENDOR COUPLE REFEREE LAWYER
MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER OKAY.
OTHER IN IF YOU REFERENCES TO TO
US TODAY SO I'M GONNA ACTUALLY
START WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON INLAND EMPIRE
HEALTH PLAN. UP A JENNIFER SALES
IN THE CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER
THERE AND WHERE THE LOCAL
INITIATIVE MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
PLAN. IN THIS RESERVE REGION
RESIDENTIALLY JOINT POWERS
AGENCY AJP A THAT WAS CREATED BY
BOTH COUNTIES IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX.
TO RUN A MEDICAL HEALTH PLANS WE
ARE THE PUBLIC PLAN WITH PUBLIC
DOLLARS. THAT WE ARE LEVERAGING
HERE JUST. BY WAY OF REFERENCE
THAT WE SERVE ABOUT ONE POINT
TWO FIVE MILLION MEMBERS THE
VAST VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE OUR
MEDIC HAVE MEDI CAL.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOLKS THAT ARE DUAL
ELIGIBLES OF THEIR MEDICARE
MEDICAID OUT JUST TO A PLAY OUT
REGIONALLY WITHOUT MEANS THAT'S
ABOUT ONE IN FOUR RESIDENTS IN
BOTH AND PORTANTINO IT RIVERS
LIKE.
THAT ARE THAT ARE AYE EACH PP
ASIANS
AND TO QUALIFY FOR FOR MEDI CAL
FOR THOSE WHO MAY NOT BE
FAMILIAR ITS PREDOMINATELY AT.
RESIDENTS AND INCOME REQUIREMENT
OF UNDER AND THIRTY PERCENT OF
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WHICH FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL IS BETWEEN TEN AND
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO. IN OUR WORLD.
OUR MANAGED CARE MODEL ALLOWS
US SOME FLEXIBILITY TO MEET THE
HEALTH NEEDS OF THE POPULATION
THAT WE SERVE AND IMPORTANTLY
REINVEST SAVINGS BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY FOR OUR ULTIMATE GOAL
OF. IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
SO WHY HOUSING AND HEALTH WHY AT
THREE PM AND FRIDAY IS A
PHYSICIAN SITTING UP HERE
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT HOUSING.
.
SO. INTERESTINGLY.
AS A HEALTH PLAN HER GOAL IS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH AND IF YOU LOOK
AT.
WHAT ACTUALLY IMPACT HEALTH AND
I THINK THAT THIS IS WELL KNOWN
TO THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN ILL
HAD FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE ILL
OR BEEN IN THE COMMUNITY BUT BUT
US IN THE? ACADEMIC WORLD IN
LITERATURE ROLE THERE WITH A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER BEHIND.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
FACTORS THAT AFFECT HEALTH AND
ACTUALLY THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
PRETTY SENTINEL STUDIES IN THE
MEDICAL LITERATURE THAT TALK
ABOUT. HOW MUCH?
HEALTH CARE ACTUALLY IMPACT
HEALTH AND YOU CAN SEE ON THIS
SLIDE IT'S ABOUT TEN PERCENT.
THAT MAY HELP TO WARD OFF
PREMATURE DEATH AND REALLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT.
REALLY AT LARGE COMBINATION OF
BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH PATTERNS OF SOCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
EXPOSURES WHICH BY COMPARISON
RELATE TO ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF
HEALTH AND THEN WE HAVE GENETICS
AND SO. IN THIS EQUATION IF OUR
GOAL IS TO IMPACT THE HEALTH OF
OUR MEMBERS AND HOPEFULLY BY
EXTENSION THE HEALTH OF FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES. AROUND THEM WE
NEED TO BE BROADER WE NEED TO BE
MORE HOLISTIC WE CAN'T FOCUS
ONLY ON THE HEALTH CARE THAT
WOULD BE THAT'S BEING DELIVERED.
SO WE CALL THIS APPROACH OF
LOOKING AT SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH. AND.
AND WE AT AYE HP HAVE TAKEN AND.
A PRETTY ACTIVE.
ROLE IN TRYING TO STRATEGICALLY.
THINK ABOUT AN INVEST WHERE WE
CAN GET.
THE MOST IMPACT IN TERMS OF OF
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
HOUSING IS COME UP AS NUMBER ONE
IN TERMS OF.
AWARE WE MIGHT HAVE SOME OF THE
STRONGEST IMPACT.
AND I THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF
DATA OUT IN THE LITERATURE THAT
I CAN SAY TODAY ABOUT WHY THAT'S
THE CASE. I THINK MOST OF US
PROBABLY.
RECOGNIZE IF WHERE IN THIS
WORLD WHAT THAT CONNECTION LOOKS
LIKE ALL GIVEN EXAMPLE A MEMBER
MISTER PER AS WHICH IS NOT HIS
REAL NAME BECAUSE WE CHANGED IT.
WHO HAS CHRONIC DIABETES?
HAS.
PAIN IN HIS LIMBS BECAUSE ABOUT
DIABETES IN THE POOR CONTROL
DIABETES HAS ULCERS ON HIS LEGS.
AND HAS BEEN IN AND OUT OF THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT OF A
HOSPITAL.
HE'S PROBABLY.
MAYBE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND TO
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN
TERMS OF HOW MUCH WE'RE PAYING
FOR HEALTH SERVICES FOR HIM.
HIS PHYSICIANS ARE ALL
FRUSTRATED THAT HE'S NOT TAKING
HIS INSULIN AND ON HIS TEST
STRIPS AND IF YOU JUST DIG A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER YOU WOULD
LEARN THAT HE. RECENTLY LOST HIS
HOUSING WHERE HE WAS STAYING
WITH HIS AUNT AND THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A STABLE SOURCE
OF HOUSING HE'S ACTUALLY AND
SHELTERED THAT HIS DAILY
ACTIVITY IS OBVIOUSLY FOCUSED ON
WHERE AM I GOING TO SEE TONIGHT
HOW AM I GONNA STAY SAFE WHERE'S
MY NEXT MEAL COMING FROM. AND
WHETHER OR NOT HE'S YOU KNOW
ABLE TO MONITOR HIS BLOOD SUGAR
IS VERY LOW ON THE LEFT AND SO I
THINK IT HEALTH CARE WE
SOMETIMES REFERRED ABOUT WE MAKE
JUDGMENTS.
I THINK LISA TALKED ABOUT THIS
A LITTLE THAT WE'VE REFER TO
THIS AS NON COMPLIANCE. THAT'S
REALLY NOT THE CASE AT THE VERY
RATIONAL DECISION THAT HE'S
MAKING IN HIS CURRENT CONTACTS
THAT WE NEED TO OF THE HEALTH
SYSTEM RECOGNIZE THAT AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE BUILD AROUND IT.
DON'T GO FOR YOU YEAH YOU
MENTIONED THE LITERATURE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW ABOUT WHERE
WHERE THE LITERATURE BUT.
I'D LOVE TO
GET IT.
ALL SENATORS THIS WOULD HAVE A
MUCH YOUNGER SLIDE DECK I
CONSIDER HAD ALTERED REFERENCE
ERA.
I THINK THOSE OF US WHO
POLICYMAKERS WE KNOW THIS
ANECDOTALLY BUT IF OUR IS
ACTUALLY SCIENTIFICALLY INVENTED
LITERATURE ON IT IN. MEDICAL
JOURNALS AND OTHERS THAT WOULD
BE GREAT TO SEE YA ABSOLUTELY
IMMIGRANT USUALLY DO THAT FOR
YOU THANK THANK YOU FOR SURE.
SO.
FOR A FOR US AND I AGE P. THIS
IS TRANSLATED INTO OUR FIRST.
STEPPED INTO THE HOUSING WORLD
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF GUIDANCE
THANKFULLY FROM OUR.
FAVOR TO DENOTE A COUNTY HEARD
YOUR PARTNERS PARTICULARLY.
AND SO I WILL DEFINITELY
PROFESSED TO KNOW THE LEAST
ABOUT HOUSING OF OUR PAY HER
WHOLE. OF BUT I I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE DOING AND
REALLY OF MOST OF IT IS IS IS
THAT.
FOCUS ON ON COLLABORATION SO.
WE LOOK TO GAPS WE LOOKED AT
WHERE OUR FOLKS HAVING A HARD
TIME ACCESS THING.
ARE WEARING OUR OUR POPULATION
BY EACH P. MEMBERS ARE THERE NOT
NECESSARILY.
GREAT.
.
PROGRAMS VOUCHERS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND WHERE COULD WE
PLAY AGAIN AND ALSO ECONOMICALLY
BECAUSE WE NEED TO CONSIDER THAT
FIRST ROUND WHERE'S THAT MAKES
THAT SO WE IDENTIFIED TWO GROUPS
THAT WE ARE. WORKING WITH A ONE
IS THOSE MEMBERS AND LONG TERM
CARE AND THIS IS AN INTERESTING
SITUATION.
SOME MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PERSONALLY.
AND AT AYE HP WE'VE ABOUT
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS WHO
ARE IN LONG TERM CARE AND WE
ESTIMATE ABOUT TWENTY TO THIRTY
PERCENT OF THEM. ACTUALLY DON'T
NEED TO BE THERE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE FACILITY IN FOR
NURSING CARE.
AND THOSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYWHERE TO GO AND THAT IS THE
PREDOMINANT REASON THAT THEY'RE
THERE AND SO.
WE LOOKED AT WE ARE WE ARE
ACTUALLY ENDED THINK OUR FIRST
PATIENT CAME THROUGH TWO WEEKS
AGO WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW
COULD WE. TRANSITION FOLKS WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN LIVING BACK IN
THE COMMUNITY AND DON'T HAVE A
SKILLED NEED AND REALLY COULD
WITH SUPPORTS BE SUCCESSFUL. UP
MOVE BACK IN TRANSITION TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HAVE SEVERAL
PARTNERS WERE WORKING WITH THAT
I WILL TALK ABOUT IN A MINUTE
AND OUR GOAL OVER THE NEXT
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS IS TO
TRANSITION A HUNDRED AND FIFTY.
INDIVIDUALS INTO OUT OF ONE
TERM CARE BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
OUR SECOND POPULATION IS THE
OTHER BUBBLE UP THERE AND THAT
IS WHO WE ARE WHO.
WHERE WHERE ARE THREE EACH
MEMBERS OF THESE ARE FOLKS THAT
ARE?
USING A WHOLE LOT OF HEALTH
SERVICES ARE PRETTY UNSTABLE IN
TERMS OF THEIR.
BOTH PHYSICAL BEHAVIORAL
CONDITIONS AND.
ARE HOMELESS AND AMONG THOSE WE
HAVE SOME THAT WE NOR ELIGIBLE
FOR HUD VOUCHERS AND WE PARTNER
CLOSELY AND LOOK AT MATCHING
FUNDS FOR FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
INDIVIDUALS AND LEVERAGING THE
COUNTIES.
INTO THAT HAVING HIS MANAGEMENT
SUPPORT FOR THOSE. WE HAVE A
WHOLE LOT WHO ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR HUD ABOUT FUNDING AND SO IF
WE'RE PAYING.
ON AVERAGE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR THESE FOLKS
WHICH WE ARE FOR THEIR MEDICAL
CARE.
FOR US IT MAKES.
BOTH HUMAN AND ECONOMIC SENSE
TO LOOK AT HOW WE SUPPORT.
THEIR HOUSING AS WELL.
SO SO THAT THAT GROUP WE ARE
LOOKING AT RENTALS SUPPORT IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THE SUPPORT
OF RAP SERVICES THAT WE WOULD
NORMALLY PROVIDE AND SO THIS IS
OUR FIRST ROUND OF LOOKING AT. A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
MODEL.
AND APPROACH IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
RESOURCES.
SO. YOU MIGHT OUT SCHOOL HOW
DOES THIS ACTUALLY WORK AND
WHERE DID THE DOLLARS COME FROM
SO AT THIS POINT OUR BOARD HAS
GRACIOUSLY APPROVED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR US TO START THIS
WORK. OF AND THIS IS ACROSS THE
TWO COUNTIES OF RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNIE DO YOU KNOW.
.
I AM CHOOSING THE THE MEMBERS
THAT WE WOULD BE WORKING WITH WE
LOOKED AT SEVERAL FACTORS.
INTO OBVIOUSLY HOW MIGHT
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES WE ALSO
LOOKED AT PUBS WERE PUBLIC
AGENCY WERE USING PUBLIC DOLLARS
SO WE WENT UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND
OF SAVINGS AND ECONOMIC PIECE
COULD WEIGH AND. AND SO FOR OUR
LONG TERM CARE GROUP
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
THOSE FOLKS ARE ESSENTIALLY
RECEIVING HOUSING BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO BE
ANYWHERE ELSE AND WE'RE PAYING
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH ON
AVERAGE FOR THEM.
AND WE KNOW WE COULD SUPPORT
THEIR HOUSING PLUS ALL OF THEIR
INCOME SUPPORT SERVICES AND
OTHER NEEDS LIKELY FOR AROUND
HALF THAT COST.
SO IN ADDITION TO OBVIOUSLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WHICH IS
IMPROVING QUALITY OF LIFE AND
HEALTH FOR THAT GROUP.
I THINK IT ALSO ARGUES THAT
THAT IS A GOOD USE OF OF DOLLARS
OVERALL.
THE SECOND POPULATION IN THIS
IS WHERE A LOT OF THE LITERATURE
STANDS SO THAT'S WHAT ALL THE
FOLLOWING UP WITH THAT THE
COMMITTEE ON.
IS LOOKING AT THOSE FOLKS THAT
ARE REALLY UNSTABLE AND USING
LOTS OF HEALTH SERVICES I HAVE
MULTIPLE COMORBIDITIES AND SO
THERE ARE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING OUT
IS TREATING. RENTALS SUPPORT AND
GETTING SOME OF STABILIZE IN
PERMITS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WITH
THOSE WRAP AROUND HIS MANAGEMENT
SERVICES FOR MANY MANY DAYS IN
THE HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT SO FINE AVERAGE IN
SPENDING TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY. ON SOMEONE IN A
HOSPITAL AND A LOT OF OUR COUNTY
HOSPITALS HAVE FOLKS INCLUDING
AIR WHO REGIONAL WHO'VE BEEN
THERE FOR MONTHS.
WE COULD REALLY MUCH MORE
USEFUL USE THOSE RESOURCES TO.
ACTUALLY HOW THOSE FOLKS I MEAN
FOR ME WITH A FOR US FOR THE
MARKET RATE THE WAY IT IS IF I
AVOID SEVEN DAYS IN THE HOSPITAL
I COULD PAY A YEAR.
SO YOU KNOW THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THOSE TRADE OFFS ARE AND AND
WHAT THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE TO
BETTER IMPROVE. THE SITUATION
FAIR FOR THOSE MEMBERS IS A SORT
OF CRITICAL TO US.
.
I I PAUSED AND MOVE ON JUST TO
MY LAST FLIGHT ON OUR PARTNERS
BECAUSE THEY ARE CRITICAL. AND I
I NEED TO POINT OUT THAT IF YOU
ARE I'M THINKING YOU'RE ALREADY
KNOW BUT.
CMS DOES NOT ALLOW HOUSING
COSTS TO BE IN MEDICAID
PROGRAMMING SO WE ARE DOING THIS
WITH OUR RESERVES AND THAT IS
PART OF THAT MANAGED CARE MODEL
IN THE FACT THAT IF WE CAN.
BETTER MANAGE PATIENTS AND SAVE
GENERALLY IN PATIENT BECAUSE WE
CAN REINVEST THOSE DOLLARS IT'S
A PUBLIC AGENCY BACK INTO. OF
THE COMMUNITY AND IMPACTFUL
PROGRAMS AND SO THIS IS ONE OF
THE IMPACT OF PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE CHOSEN. IT'S PROBABLY NOT A
SUSTAINABLE.
MODEL IN THE SENSE THAT.
WE NEED LONG TERM TO BE LOOKING
AT BETTER. OF FINDING AN
INTEGRATED SOLUTIONS BUT IT'S
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO NOW.
SO IN TERMS OF PARTNERS.
I HAVE TO MY RIGHT ONE OF OUR
GREAT PARTNERS IN THE COUNTY OF
HOW IN THE COUNTY DEPARTMENTS.
ARE BOTH THE HOUSING AGENCY AND
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
STRONG PARTNERS WE OBVIOUSLY
MATCH WITH THEM FOR VOUCHERS THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT WE
LOOK AT WHAT WHO THEY CAN HOUSE
WHO WE CAN HOUSE IF THERE'S
OVERLAPPED. OF MEMBERSHIP.
US ABOUT BEEN A REALLY IMPORTANT
AND CRITICAL PARTNER WE ALSO ARE
WORKING WITH.
INSTITUTE ON AGING WHICH IS
PROVIDING A LOT OF THOSE
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES FOR OUR
MEMBERS OUT OF LONG TERM CARE.
WE PARTNER WITH MULTIPLE LOCAL
ICM AS ORGANIZATIONS FOR THAT
AND HAS A HOUSING HIS MANAGEMENT
PIECE.
AS IDENTIFIED BY THE COUNTIES
THAT WE'RE WE'RE LEVERAGING
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WE ALSO
WORKING WITH BRILLIANT CORNERS
THAT THAT IS.
LOOKING AT QUIRK COORDINATING
THESE HOUSING EFFORTS FROM THAT
PROPERTY RELATED TENDENCY
SERVICES PERSPECTIVE.
SCORING LA RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LOCAL DEVELOPERS FOR FASHION FOR
MATCHING FUNDS AND THEN FINALLY.
WE HAVE A IMPLEMENTED AIRS
ALISON FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
POOL THAT WERE HOPEFUL OVER TIME
WILL CERTAINLY ALLOW US
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW WE LEVERAGE
OUR DOLLARS BUT WILL ALSO ALLOW
PARTNERS TO CONTRIBUTE.
TO A REGIONAL APPROACH TO THIS
PROBLEM.
SO THAT IS.
AREA HEALTH.
LET ME JUST
UPON WHAT YOU JUST LAID OUT
THIS.
TEN MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
YOU'RE DOING TO BASICALLY RUN
THE PILOT AND PROVE THAT IT'S
FAR CHEAPER TO.
TO PUT A ROOF OVER SOMEONE'S
HEAD WAS SUPPORT HOUSING MEANT
TO.
ONE EL ON THE STREETS I IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
DO WITH.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF AB SEVENTY
FOUR DO YOU RECEIVE.
MEDICARE WHOLE PERSON CARE
FUNDS SHOULD THOSE FUNDS GO TO
THE COUNTIES.
SO CONSIGNA YOU YOU KNOW YOU
CAN SPEAK TO TO.
TO THOSE BUT THAT MANAGE
SCHEMATIC HOW MANAGED CARE PLANS
ARE PARTNER WITH THE COUNTIES ON
THOSE BUT.
ARE NOT DIRECT RECIPIENTS OF
THOSE FUNDS BUT WHAT I'M
WONDERING THIS MAYBE AT ANOTHER
CONVERSATION SEPARATE THEM. THIS
HEARING BUT THERE THERE MAY BE
SOME STATE FUNDS AVAILABLE TO
YOU COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THROUGH OUR AB SEVEN FOUR
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW THE STATE IS
LOOKING FOR. A NUMBER
JURISDICTIONS ARE WILLING TO DO
EXACTLY THESE TYPES OF EYELIDS
EIGHT HOUSES SO I IS JUST OFF
THE GUIDES SEEMS LIKE THAT. IS A
WORTHY CONVERSATION THE OTHER
THING I. WANT TOASK IS WHY DID
YOUR HEALTH PLAN DECIDE TO DO
THIS.
ARE OTHERS CONSIDERING THIS WERE
OUT OF HOW DID.
WHAT WHAT WAS THE INSPIRATION
PART OF WHAT I THINK SHOULD BE
AN OBVIOUS THING BUT OBVIOUSLY
YOU'VE TAKEN A LEADERSHIP ROLE?
SURE NO I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION SO.
SO WHY ARE HEALTH PLAN.
IS REALLY WHEN WE STARTED TO DO
THAT LOOK UPSTREAM AT WHAT IS
IMPACTING THE HEALTH OF OUR
MEMBERS THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE AND
LIKE I'LL GIVE YOU THE LETTER TO
SUPPORT IT BUT IT'S REALLY OUR
EVERYDAY EXPERIENCE I THINK THAT
DROVE US. WE ARE NOT ONLY HEALTH
PLAN DOING THIS ACTUALLY ON
THEIR SEVERAL PUBLIC PLANS.
LIKE OURSELVES. IN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE THAT ARE
DOING DIFFERENT APPROACHES. OF
SAN MATEO HEALTH PLAN ACTUALLY
SPEARHEADED THE LONG TERM CARE.
EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE THE WE'RE
ACTUALLY USING A LOT OF BEST
PRACTICE FROM THAT IN HOURS. I
CAME FROM LA COUNTY OF HEALTH
SERVICES IN THE AGENCY THERE AND
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF OUR
MODELING AROUND.
THE.
THAT THE HIGH USE POPULATION
CAME FROM SO.
THEIR PLANS THERE ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE COUNTIES OF
THAT THE COUNTY CAN HAVE A
FOUGHT A ROBUST FLEXIBLE HOUSING
COOL TO BE ABLE TO IT'S A SERVE
SO. THERE ARE DEFINITELY ORANGE
COUNTY IS DOING HEALTH PLAN IS
DOING ON A LOT OF RECOUP PART OF
CARE AND OTHER SMALLER PROJECTS.
SO THERE IT'S IT'S AN INTEREST
OF THE HEALTH PLANS AND I THINK
IT'S AN IMPERATIVE.
FOR US TO GET WHERE WE WANT TO
GO WITH THE HEALTH OF YOU KNOW
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WELL THANK YOU AND IF YOU ED.
THANK AND A BASIC ASKING YOU
CIVIC CENTER LURCHER INFORMATION
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO SEND MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND HIGHER
SPENDING THAT. MONEY AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO PUT YOU IN TOUCH WITH
SOME OF THE FOLKS AT THE STATE
LEVEL THAT ARE WORKING ON ABC
REPORTER STEVE THAT'S A PORT AND
HAVE THE SITUATION. THEY HAVE
SUCH A ONE THING THAT I JUST
THOUGHT THAT THAT I WANTED TO
MENTION EARLY AND I LIKE TO SEE
SIMONE LEGAL TO DO THAT GOING
BACK TO THE HOMELESSNESS AND
WOMEN HOMELESS WOMEN HERE. IS
THAT THE ONE OF FOUR THAT YOU'VE
BEEN HEARING ABOUT AND THAT'S
INITIATIVE HERE IT'S THE IT'S
THE COUNTY HAS TAKEN A NINE AND
IT'S THE FIRST SUCH INITIATIVE
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND I WANTED TO DRIVE THAT POINT
HOME FOR THE SAKE OF BASEL
SAYING THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
KEEP YOU INFORMED. AS TO THE GAS
HOW THIS INITIATIVE IS
DEVELOPING.
IT IS THE FIRST ONE.
I I I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY ALL
THE NEWSPAPER ARTICLES I READ
ABOUT THAT STE.
SO I'M VERY GLAD YOU MENTIONED
THAT I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR
YOU WHICH IS AB AND A COMMENT.
THIS YEAR.
FORTUNATELY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND I.
ARE ARE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
PART IN THE BUDGET PROCESS WE
HAVE ACTUALLY A BIT OF A HEALTHY
SURPLUS THIS YEAR SIX BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS AND. A NUMBER OF
US HAVE PROPOSED THAT A QUARTER
OF THAT SURPLUS ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS BE DEVOTED THIS
YEAR TO HOMELESS SERVICES ARE
STATE.
NOW I THINK ACAPELLA COUNTED
DOZEN OF US OUT OF EIGHTY SO FAR
WHO WERE KIND OF ON BOARD OF
THAT BUT WE'RE TRYING TO GROW
OUR NUMBERS AND. MY GUESS IS
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM WOULD
SUPPORT THAT.
THERE IS A DISCUSSION GOING ON
ABOUT WHETHER IT'S WHETHER WE
SHOULD PRIORITIZE RAPIDLY
HOUSING DOLLARS.
VERSES RENTAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT OF HOUSE
AND.
CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE A
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT.
YES DIDN'T GLANCE ONE QUESTION
TWO IS THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION TO STEP HIGH TO THE
ELEVEN SITTINGS.
I CHECKED IS THAT TIED TO THE
ELEVEN CITIES THAT IS ELEVEN
CITIES PROPOSAL BECAUSE BUT
THAT'S NOT WHY AMBER TO DO YOU
KNOW THAT ONE OF. RIGHT NOW I AM
AWARE OF THAT. SO SO THE ELEVEN
I I WANT TO THE INTERVIEW YET NO
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
SO IT'S INTERESTING. THAT THE
BIG THIRTEEN MAYORS
OF CALIFORNIA HAD PROPOSED THAT
AND CERTAINLY THE QUESTION IS
COMING FROM OTHER PARTS YOU
DON'T REPRESENT THOSE THIRTEEN
CITIES HOW DO WE GET SOME OF US
MONEY AND THAT. THE IDEA HAS
BEEN IF A JURISDICTION HAS SKIN
IN THE GAME IF THEY'RE WILLING
TO.
COUNTY OR CITY IS KIND OF A SOME
DOLLARS THAT THERE BE A
MATCHING.
SIMILAR THAT'S OR TALK ABOUT BUT
ALL THAT BEING SAID YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY HOMELESSNESS HAS A
FACE EVERYWHERE AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A TRUE THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE AT ONCE HE
ALTERS SIX.
WHAT IT IN ANSWER THE OTHER
QUESTION THOUGH I WOULD SAY
THAT?
WANTED PERMITTED SUPPORT OF
HOUSING YOU KNOW IF IF YOU'RE
NOT GONNA WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO DEAL. WITH CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS.
UNLESS IF WE HAVE THE PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THERE THE
JURY'S OUT ON THAT THAT IS THE
ONLY APPROPRIATE INTERVENTION
THAT WORKED FOR THE CHRONICLE
WAS.
POPULATION AND I'M I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THE EMPHASIS ON PERMITS
PART OF HOUSING BECAUSE OFTEN WE
TALK ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
YOU KNOW AND I'M HOW THAT'S
GOING TO.
YOU KNOW AND HOMELESSNESS THAT
OFTEN IS AN UNATTENDED.
HALF TRUTHS BECAUSE IT LEAVES
CHRONIC.
HOMELESS OUT OF THE EQUATION IT
AFFORDABLE HA PERMITS WERE TO
HOUSING IS PART OF. A BOMB
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT AS YOU
KNOW IT'S DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF
THE SERVICES AND ALL THAT.
SO THE CHOICE THAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS THAT. DO WE MOODY'S.
YOU KNOW THIRTY PERCENT OF OUR
POPULATION HOMELESS POPULATION
LIKE HERE IN THE COUNTY AND
ELSEWHERE OUT ON THE STREETS
WHERE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS.
ARE BY CHOOSING RAPIDLY HOUSING
DOLLARS BECAUSE RAPID RE HOUSING
DOLLARS.
OFTEN IS NOT AN APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTION.
FOR THE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE
PROVIDING.
RAPIDLY HOUSING FOR THREE MONTHS
SIX MONTHS OR EVEN UP TO THE
TOTAL OF TWO YEARS SAID IT'S
OFTEN ALLOW FOR.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS AT THE END OF
THAT YOU KNOW THE WITH SOMEBODY
WHO HAS IS A PERMANENT
DISABILITY THEIR UNEMPLOYABLE.
DO THEY FALL OUT OF HOUSING AT
THAT POINT TIME THAT BEING SAID
ON THE RAPIDLY HOUSING SIDE
WITHOUT OVERSIMPLIFYING IT SO
MUCH. IS THAT RAPIDLY HOUSING
WOULD HELP GET OUR. NON
CHRONICALLY HOMES PERKED UP
POPULATION OFF THE STREETS AND
HERE IN THE COUNTY. TAKES ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY DURING THE
HOMELESS COUNTY ASK A COUPLE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND ONE OF
THEM HAS BEEN.
DID YOU FIRST BECOME HOMELESS
DURING THE PAST TWELVE MONTHS.
AND THAT'S BEEN NO THAT'S ALSO
BEEN A ONE IN FOUR NUMBER.
THAT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT NEED TO
RAPIDLY HOUSING THE OTHER TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT OR SO NEED.
THE PERMITTED SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING I WOULD SAY. THAT
THERE'S MORE RESOURCES TO GET.
THOSE WERE NOT QUAN ACOSTA ST
STE NOT ENOUGH BUT THERE'S MORE
COMPARATIVELY SPEAKING WE NEED
OUR.
THE FUNDING. THE GOING TO PERMIT
A SPORT THOUSAND.
VERY HEALTH POINT SIR THANK YOU.
NUMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH I I AM
SO PLEASED WITH.
THE THREE OF YOU AND EVERY
OTHER.
PANELISTS WHO PROVIDED TESTIMONY
TO THE RIGHT TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION BECAUSE I DO WANT
THE CHAIR OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE TO. UNDERSTAND SAN
BERNARDINO IN A WAY THAT I COULD
NEVER DESCRIBE TO HIM.
AND AS DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE
IN THE HOUSING COMMITTEE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALWAYS WHEN I
TELL HIM. DON'T FORGET SANDRA
DINO DON'T FORGET SAMBA DE NOVO
YOU'LL KNOW YOU'LL REMEMBER ALL.
EXCEPT.
AND I CAN ASSURE YOU SHE HASN'T
AND SAYING THAT ABOUT ONCE A
MONTH OR MAYBE A SO. HERE I AM
WELL THANK YOU
THE PANELISTS AND AND LOOK FOR
TO THE INFORMATION WE RECEIVE
FROM YOU.
AS I PROMISE EARLIER WE DO HAVE
A TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS AYE
FORTUNE WE NEED TO GET TO GET
BACK ON THE ROAD SO I CAN GET A
PLANE BACK TO MY CITY IN ABOUT
FORTY MINUTES BUT LET ME GET A
SHOW OF HANDS OF HOW MANY FOLKS
WOULD. LIKE TO SPEAK.
AND PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY AND THEN ANOTHER TEN.
OKAY I THINK WE HAVE TIME FOR
PUBLIC BUT A MINUTE AND A HALF
FOR EACH PERSON IF THAT WORKS.
OUT IF WE COULD USE THE
MICROPHONE IN THE BACK SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR IT OF FOLKS CAN LINE
UP.
AND.
THIS.
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS.
YEAH AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
START YOUR IT. IS WORKING YES
YES.
I DON'T START WE NEED TO GO TO
PRIVATE A MINUTE. JUST TRY TO
ESTIMATE HOW MANY HOW MANY FOLKS
ARE HERE.
.
ONE WE SAVE ONE WE SAY ONE
MINUTE AND HOPEFULLY LOVED ONES
AFTER DE TO UNDERGO CHAIRMAN
CHIU.
ASSEMBLY THE MEMBER RAISES GOMEZ
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU THIS
AFTERNOON.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT CALIFORNIA
SUFFERS FROM A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT IT ALL AFTERNOON.
BUT THE SITUATION COULD BECOME
MUCH WORSE.
IF A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE WERE TO
STRIKE.
MANY OF OUR OLDER BUILDINGS AT
RISK OF DAMAGE
EVEN MAJOR EARTHQUAKE ARE HOME
TO THE LOWER MIDDLE INCOME
RESIDENTS OF OUR. COMMUNITIES.
THESE THE STRUCTURED MAKEUP THE
BULK OF OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK EVEN MAJOR EARTHQUAKE WERE
TO STRIKE.
IT COULD BE DAMAGE OR RENDERED.
ON HABITABLE.
WHICH WOULD.
CREATE A HOUSING CRISIS THAT IS
MUCH WORSE WHAT IF AND WHAT IT
IS TODAY.
THE BIG ONE IS NOT AN IF
ANYMORE.
WHAT WENT SCIENTISTS ARE WARNING
US THEY HAVE BEEN WARNING US?
OUR BIG ONE IS GOING TO BE FORTY
FIVE TIMES LARGER THAN NORTH
BEACH IS QUICK WHICH WAS MOST
EXPENSIVE DISASTER IN US
SOCIETY.
BEFORE KATRINA TIED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH USE THAT I'LL JUST SAY
I'VE I'VE WE RECEIVED YOUR YOUR
INFORMATION I'VE WORKED WITH
MISTER NAZARIAN ON A COUPLE
BILLS IN THIS AREA I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL HAPPY TO MOVE
FOUR WITH WITHOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND WE'RE GOING TO
OBVIOUSLY TRY TO BE CONSISTENT
UNDER PUBLIC COMMENT RULES SO
THAT WE GIVE EVERYONE EQUAL
TIMES WITH THAT NEXT BIGGER.
GERMAN IS SIMPLY ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS GARY MADDEN
I AM THE.
DIRECTOR OF THE TWO ON ONE
SYSTEM HERE IN THE COUNTY I'M
ALSO THE INTERIM CEO OF INLAND
EMPIRE NOT AWAY AND WE OPERATE
TO COORDINATE INTEREST SYSTEM
FOR THE COUNTY.
I ONE OF THINGS I CAN TELL YOU
FROM TWO ONE DATA IS THAT
HOUSING APSLEY DOMINATES
EVERYTHING ELSE WE RECEIVE ABOUT
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND CALLS A
YEAR.
AND HOUSING APPEARS IN ABOUT
THIRTY THREE PERCENT OF OUR
CALLS. AS AS IT AS A JUST A
DOMINANT.
OTHER THING I WANT TO MENTION IS
THAT IN HIM YOU ASKED ABOUT THAT
ONE IN FOUR. AND IT BOTH IN OUR
STREET OUTREACH.
OBVIOUSLY THE HOMELESS COUNT AND
IN THE CLOSET TO A ONE THAT
CONSISTENT NUMBER OF WOMEN IN
SABATINO COUNTY ON A COMPANY
WOMEN IS MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT YOU MAY SEE
ACROSS THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
LAST COMMENT I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT IF.
NECESSITY IS THE MOTHER
INVENTION THAT SAN BENITO COUNTY
IS THE MOTHER OF NECESSITY.
AND THIS COUNTY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE FUNDING OR
NONPROFIT INFRASTRUCTURE ABOUT
THREE PERCENT BUT WERE FIVE AND
HALF PERCENT.
IN THE IN THE EMPIRE.
IT'S IS A BIG DEAL BUT THIS
COUNTY HAS A VISION WHICH IS
MUCH DIFFERENT THAN JUST
FOCUSING ON INDIVIDUAL PROBLEMS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS BEVERLY ORAL
AND I AM WITH CATHOLIC
CHARITIES.
AND I'M GONNA MAKE IT QUICK.
ARE WE HAVE WE DO HAVE A MAJOR
PROBLEM HERE IN OUR COUNTY.
WE'RE DEALING WITH FAMILIES THAT
LIVE WON'T EIGHT TO ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH AND A TO BEAR
ROOM IS THE ELEVEN HUNDRED.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT THIRTY
TO SIXTY PERCENT OF THE MEDIUM
INCOME. BECAUSE WE HELP ALL I'M
GONNA SAY A QUARTER. THREE HAVE
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT LIVE ON LESS THAN A
THOUSAND OR FROM THEM WRONG WITH
OUR FIGURES.
AND IN ORDER FOR FAIR MARKET
RENT.
DEBBIE TO ARE ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
TWO BATHROOMS IN OUR COUNTY GOV
ARE JOB THORN FOR YEARS DO NOT
ALL FOR. THOSE TYPES OF WAGES.
AND SO.
OUR CLIENTS DO NOT HAVE ANY
CONTROL.
ALL WERE THERE EMPLOYEE YEAR AND
WHAT OUR WORDS THEY'RE ABLE TO
WORK WITHIN A PAY PERIOD.
AND THERE WORKING BETWEEN
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
PAY PERIOD.
BECAUSE OF YOUR EMOTIONAL CARE
AT.
YOU YOU KNOW BENEFIT SOPORTE.
AND THIS IS A BIG MAJOR PROBLEM.
OF CHILD KNOW THEY'RE MADE YOUR
PROFLIGATE MUCH MA'AM.
YEAH I THOUGHT THAT BETH IT IT
FOLKS OF THAT WILSHIRE. FOLKS
ARE FREE IF YOU'D LIKE TO SEND
US ANY RED MATERIAL ALSO OUR THE
RITUAL THAT THINK THAT VERY MUCH
OUTFIT.
IT AFTERNOON THANK YOU THE
PLEASURE I'M SORT OF A
TYPEWRITTEN FOUNDATION. AND I'M%
I JUST WANNA SAY THAT WHEN I
STARTED OFF ARM FRIENDS ARE MADE
IN A COMMAND.
SEPARATELY NO COUNTY AND I JUST
WANNA SAY LIKE IT WAS A FOR
TYPEWRITTEN FOUNDATION. I WOULD
NOT I HAVE MY OWN APARTMENT
RIGHT NOW OF SIX KIDS.
.
BUT MY KIDS THAT WERE MY MOM
PRINCIPLE. BECAUSE YOUR RENT IS
TOO HIGH IN FAT MEDINA COUNTY
LIKE I CAN GIVE AN AFFORDABLE
THREE BEDROOM FOR MY CHILDREN.
AND WORK AND PAY CHILDCARE IN
SEPARATE YOU KNOW COUNTY LIKE
HIS FIRST STUDIO REPEAL BY.
ELEVEN HUNDRED LIKE.
WE NEED TO BRING THE MONEY BACK
TO THE COUNTY. INTO
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE TYPER CHANGE
SO WE CAN EXPAND AND DO THINGS
FOR MOTHERS AND CHILDREN FARMING
INCARCERATED WOMEN.
IT HELPS OUR COMMUNITY AND HELP
SAYS I'M I'M A BETTER PERSON
TODAY I HAVE MY SON AND I HAVE
MY OWN APARTMENT AND THAT'S THE
TIME FOR CHANGE.
SO WHEN YOU GUYS DO WHATEVER YOU
DO I JUST WANNA SAY CAN YOU
BRING THE FUNDS BACK THAT'S TO
THE COUNTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
THANKS REPRESENTED TIME FOR
CHANGE NEXT BECAUSE PLEASE.
MY NAME IS BOBBY BAR ITSELF.
AND.
.
I AM I DO ESTATE DEVELOPER WE
ARE BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND WE HAVE CREATED NEW PROGRAM
A FIVE.
FUNDING VEHICLE FOR THE CITY
AND FOR THE COUNTY AND FOR THE
WHOLE ENOUGH EMPIRE.
AND THAT WILL BE LAUNCHING IT ON
APRIL TWENTY SIXTH
AND I LIKE TO INVITE THAT ANYONE
THAT THAT LIKES TO COMMENT.
I GOT INTO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
THAT I HEALTHCARE DOLLARS AND
HOUSING WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
REPORTS THAT YOU CAN FIND ON ALL
WEBSITE. AND IT'S DESCRIBED
EXACTLY WHAT AND HOW WE ARE
BUILDING AT.
THANK YOU.
EXPECT.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS HEATHER
STANNING FROM OPTION HOUSE AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND AND. OFFERING US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU I
REALLY WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN SAMBOR NAY DINO
HOWEVER. WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
HOW PROUD WE ARE THAT THE
MONIES.
OR EXCUSE ME THAT OUR OUR
NUMBERS OF HOMELESS HAVE GONE
DOWN. WELL THEY'VE GONE THIS
THEY GUNNED LA.
AND THEN LA US IN THE BACK DOWN
HERE SO WE'RE JUST TRADING HOME
LIBERTIES TRADING BODIES BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN COUNTIES AND
WE REALLY NEED TO REALIZE. JUST
ACCEPT THAT BACK.
SO WITH THAT IF WE COULD ASK YOU
PLEASE PLEASE TO JUST ASSIST US
IN ANY POSSIBLE IN IDENTIFYING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. FOR THIS
COMMUNITY FOR SAMMY DINO COUNTY
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT YOU IN
YOUR EFFORTS AS YOU GO TO
SACRAMENTO.
GREAT THANK YOU.
WHAT ABOUT JESSICA MOMENT AND
SAVE YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WE
PASSED S. B. TO?
FIRST.
ESTABLISHMENT OF A PERMANENT
SOURCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING HALF
THE MONIES OF THAT. ARE SUPPOSE
TO GO THIS YEAR TO HOMELESSNESS
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THAT PLEASE CHECK THAT OUT.
AND THEN A FOR SUCCESSFUL ON
NOVEMBER ELECTION DAY WILL HAVE
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS OF THAT MONEY UNDER
THAT BOND MEASURE. ARE SLATED TO
GO TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT NEEDS
SO THAT YOU'LL DEFINITELY CHECK
THAT OUT AS WELL. YES.
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN REYES
CHAIRMAN. TO AND MOST OF ALL
LISA. THANK YOU I KNOW YOU'RE
THE HARDEST WORKER SHEARS THANK
YOU FOR COMING DECEMBER DID YOU
KNOW THE LARGEST COUNTY IN THE
WORLD.
UNFORTUNATELY WE GET THE LESS
LEAST AMOUNT OF STATE FUNDS
DECEMBER NINETEEN OH COUNTY BUT
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN REYES
FIGHTING FOR US OVER THERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I'M WITH IT AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN OFFICE IN
HERE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE. AND
WE ARE COMMITTED TO ASSISTING
OUR RESIDENTS REGARDING INCOME
DISCRIMINATION IN HOUSING.
THE CALIFORNIA INCOME
DISCRIMINATION WHAT DOES NOT
PROTECT SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER
TENANTS. HOWEVER IN FEBRUARY
TWENTY SIXTEEN SENATOR LINO
INTRODUCED THE STATE BILL S. B.
TEN FIFTY THREE WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
VOUCHERS WILDER.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS PLACED ON
SUSPENSE FILE IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I'M
HERE TO ASK YOU WHY.
AND HOW YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN REYES
WILL REPRESENT US IN THE HIGH
<c.green> BY SPONSORING THIS
BILL.</c>
AND MAKING SURE IT GETS PASSED
NEXT SESSION.
TELL ME THE NAME OF THE BILL
AGAIN.
I'LL MAKE SURE I GET THE
INFORMATION TO YOU IN YOUR
OFFICE YOUR OFFICE IS AMAZING
IT'S S. B. TEN FIFTY THREE AND
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES SAID IN
INTERVIEWS MY NAME IT'S DESIREE
SANCHEZ WITH THE ACLU.
THANK YOU DOES OR.
I SPEAKER.
HELLO EVERYONE AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE THE PANELISTS.
I REALLY JUST WANT TO.
THINKING WHICH SHOW GRATITUDE
FOR THE INTERSECTION OF HOUSING
JUSTICE AS WELL AS HEALTHCARE
JUSTICE.
AND THAT REALLY GOES IN LINE
WITH THE WORK THAT WE'RE BEEN
DOING HERE IN THE COMMUNITY.
IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING THREE
INITIATIVES.
WITH THE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU FOR.
PRODUCING THAT OF BEING A
CHAMPION ON THAT'S AND THE
STATEWIDE PROHIBITION ON RENT
CONTROL. OF ELIGIBLE UNITS.
MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO HAPPENS
TO BE MISTER STEINORTH LIKES TO
SAY THAT THERE'S A.
THERE'S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM NOW
THERE'S STABILIZATION FOR A
RENTS IN OUR TENANTS TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES.
THE OTHER INITIATIVE THAT WE'RE
ARE LOOKING AT IS TO CLOSE THE
CORPORATE LOOPHOLE OF
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. EITHER
WERE TRYING TO GET SIGNATURES
RIGHT NOW IN THE PROCESS TO
AUTOMATE THE CORPORATIONS PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE IN PROPERTY
TAXES.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT RESTORING
UP TO FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
DECEMBER YOU KNOW COUNTY ON THAT
WILL BE SHARED FOR.
COMMUNITY SERVICES SUCH AS TIME
WENT OF HOUSING AND OTHERS AS
WELL AND OF COURSE AS WELL ARE
MOVING OUT SB FIVE SIXTY TWO OUT
OF COMMITTEE SO WE CAN NOW.
SAY THREE THIRTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS EVERY SINGLE
YEAR BY GUARANTEEING HEALTHCARE
IS A RIGHT FOR ALL PEOPLE THANK
YOU.
GIVEN MUCH.
THERE ARE MANY IT THEY'RE
LEAVING THE FAMILY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND I WAS TROUBLED THAT
THERE WAS NO DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOMELESS YOUTH AT THIS MEETING.
ALTHOUGH I WASN'T SURPRISED.
I.
SIMILAR COUNTY REALLY HAS LAGGED
IN THAT AREA I THINK THAT THE
LEADERSHIP OF SUPERVISOR ALMOST
IS REALLY MADE A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT OR STARTING TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON THAT. A PART OF THE
HOMELESS YOUTH TASK FORCES
ALLOWED US TO BRING IN FUNDING
WE CURRENTLY RECEIVE ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF STATE
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE FUNDING. TO
SERVE THE HOMELESS YOUTH
THROUGHOUT SERIAL COUNTY WE HAVE
ALMOST A HUNDRED THAT'S NO.
I AND WHAT I WAS I'D LIKE TO
REALLY ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
SUPPORT SENATE BILL NINETEEN.
WHICH I BELIEVE AS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GOMEZ REYES HAS
ALREADY AUTHORED BY THE SIGNED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR THANKS ALONG
WITH I THINK ALMOST A CO AUTHORS
OF THAT THE ACT THINGS ARE VERY
MUCH. ALMOST EVERY ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES AND WE KNOW
COUNTY HAS SIGNED ON AS A CO
AUTHOR SOME PRETTY CONFIDENT
THAT MIGHT GET PAST.
BUT THAT'S CREATES THE OFFICE OF
HOMELESS YOUTH THAT SACRAMENTO
AND IT ALSO CREATES SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT WILL
GO TO HELP SERVE HOMELESS YOU
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTY AND
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. SO I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT I HOPE
YOU GUYS ALL WILL FORCE THAT
THROUGH THANK YOU.
UP THANK YOU CHAIRMAN CHIU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS A JAKO
SIMI FROM MARY ERICSSON
COMMUNITY HOUSING FOR SMALL
SCALE. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER HERE IN THE COUNTY.
I WANTED TO ECHO MY FRIEND TO
CARTER'S A CONCERNS ABOUT OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL SCALE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IF DONE CORRECTLY WE CAN
DELIVER.
OF JUST AS MANY UNITS
EFFICIENTLY AND MORE CHEAPLY.
IF DONE CORRECTLY ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE DIFFERENT DEVELOPMENT
CONCERNS AND ISSUES THAT FACE OF
THE THE NATIONAL CHORDS OF THE
WORLD TO PLEASE DON'T FORGET THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL SCALE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
NEXT AWARE PLEASED AND S. B.
THREE THAT THERE I UNDERSTAND
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND CAL HOME FUNDING FOR DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE BUT
WONDERFUL.
A HOMES HOUSING IS VERY
IMPORTANT WE UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
ALSO HOME OWNERSHIP FOR LOW
INCOME ALSO HAS TREMENDOUS
STABILIZING IMPACTS ON OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY SO PLEASE DON'T FORGET
ABOUT.
HOUSING HOME OWNERSHIP FOR LOW
INCOME.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WEEK OF.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I MARIE FLANNERY I'M
THE CEO IT INLAND FAIR HOUSING
IN MEDIATION BOARD.
WE WORK TO FURTHER FAIR HOUSING
THROUGHOUT THE INLAND EMPIRE.
AND.
THROUGH OUR EDUCATION OUTREACH
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES OF WE
ALSO HAVE UNLIMITED MEDIATION
PROGRAM A PROVIDE HOUSING
COUNSELING TO INLAND EMPIRE
RESIDENTS.
I YOU KNOW IT'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN
A TOUGH LOVE FEW MONTHS FOR FAIR
HOUSING BUT. I KID I'M NOT GONNA
WASTE MY MINUTE ON THAT WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO GO. WITH IT WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS ON IS THAT
CALIFORNIA I KNOW LAST SUMMER
THERE HAS THERE IT WAS THE LAST
ACTIVITY ON IT BUT AB SIX EIGHTY
SIX. WAS AND AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING STATUTE
THAT THE CITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WAS LOOKING AT.
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
SOME FOLKS AT THE NATIONAL
HOUSING LAW PROJECT TO PROPOSE
THAT LEGISLATION AND I WOULD
URGE YOU GUYS TO TAKE THAT BACK
UP BECAUSE AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. UNDERMINES OUR.
YOU KNOW OUR FAIR HOUSING
PROGRESS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN PICK THAT TORCH RIGHT BACK
UP AND ALSO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS A.
AN EXTENSION OF. THE HOUSE HOW
HOMEOWNER BILL OF RIGHTS.
ACT THAT'S CURRENTLY PENDING
ITS S. B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT AND I
THINK THAT THE PROVISIONS IN THE
HOMEOWNER BILL OF RIGHTS ARE
STILL RELEVENT.
WE DO HOUSING COUNSELING IN YES
TECHNICALLY THE FORECLOSURE
CRISIS IS OVER BUT PEOPLE STILL
NEED THOSE PROTECTIONS
ESPECIALLY AS OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS WORKING TO
UNDERMINE. OF YOU KNOW.
UNDERMINE THE.
YOU KNOW.
.
HOME TO DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SO THOSE TWO THINGS I
WOULD LIKE YOU GUYS TO
IF YOU LOOK AT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ISSUE.
BY THE WAY I'LL SAY THAT THE
FAIR HOUSING BILL IS SOMETHING
THAT I SUPPORTED DO MOVE OUT OF
OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE OTHER ONE BUT WILL WILL
LOOK AT THAT.
GREAT THANKS.
NEXT WEEK.
I GOOD AFTERNOON DON SMITH
MEMBER OF THE LOCAL I SEE EIGHT
FIRST OUR AGE VERSUS PER
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IT IT CAN'T
BE EITHER OR WE HAVE TO HAVE
BOTH. BUT THE REALITY IS A
MILLION DOLLARS THAT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE ANNUALLY OVER FIVE
YEARS WILL SERVE ABOUT A SEVEN
HOUSEHOLD FOR PERMITS PART OF
HOUSING OVER FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN HOUSEHOLDS. THEIR RAPID RE
HOUSING.
DID WE HAVE A SERIOUS HOUSING
CRISIS MISS CARTER HIT RIGHT ON
THE HEAD BIG BEAUTIFUL
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE COMING FIVE
SEVEN YEARS A GREAT WE NEED
THOSE. WE NEED HOUSING TODAY
SEVEN NINE PERCENT OF THE FOLKS
AT THIRTY PERCENT BELOW IT THEY
AM I PAYING OVER FIFTY PERCENT
OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING HERE
IN TIMBER NEW COUNTY. YOU HAVE
TO WORK TWO AND A HALF MINIMUM
WAGE JOBS TO AFFORD THE EFFORT
MAR RATE FOR A TWO BEDROOM HOUSE
HOLD. ITS AMBER AND YOU KNOW
COUNTY.
WE HAVE A WEB BASED CONSUMER
REQUEST.
VEHICLE THAT ACTUALLY SHOWED.
FOUR PERCENT OF THOSE
SEEKING TO.
ASSISTANCE WITH HOUSING
CHALLENGES ARE HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
NUMBER SINGLE MOTHERS WITH
CHILDREN ALLOWED BY DISCUSSIONS
FOCUS ON INDIVIDUALS WE'RE
LEAVING OUT FAMILIES TIME THE
FIFTY THOUSAND OR ON THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY LISTED SANTA. THANK
YOU MOTIONS ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR ALL.
YOU CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
ROMANOV ON DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
US OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FAULTY
BICU CHAPTER. OF.
UNDERSTANDABLE WE'RE ALL TALKING
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALSO
ONE ADDRESSED THE WORKFORCE
HOUSING ISSUES THERE ARE
AFFECTING OUR.
EMPLOYED
FOLKS FIRST YEAR POLICE OFFICERS
FIRST YEAR FIREFIGHTERS ARE HERE
IN THE COUNTYWE ARE.
VERY SHORT.
OUT OF THAT WE ARE SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNITS SHORT AND IT'S
GROWING ON A YEARLY BASIS.
WE'RE HOPING TO ADDRESS THAT
THROUGH SOME.
SEEK WERE OF BILLS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE ASSEMBLY AS IN
PARTICULAR THERE IS ONE EIGHT B.
THIRTY TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S BEING
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLYMAN ROCKY
CHAVEZ. OCEANSIDE. AYE THAT
WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE.
MEMBERS ARE FACING ON A DAILY
BASIS.
I ONLY HAVE ONE MINUTE AND IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THAT.
THIRTY PERCENT.
FAR RESIDENTS ARE PAYING MORE
INCLUDED IN TEN I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE TO KIND OF.
MINUTES SO QUICK.
BUT I DO HAVE SOME INFORMATION I
COULD DROP OFF ON MONDAY WHEN
I'M IN SACRAMENTO MISTER. CHAIR
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
REVIEWING SOME MORE PLEASE FEEL
WE'VE WE ACTUALLY OF A BILL TO
TRY TO ADDRESS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL SO HAPPY TO
HEAR YOUR IDEAS.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
ANTHONY BRAZIER HOUSING
COORDINATOR FOR FOOT HILL
PROJECTS FACILITIES PROJECT JUST
WANNA MENTION.
TWO THINGS.
A LOT ABOUT HOMELESS OR HOMELESS
BECAUSE OF. THE ECONOMICALLY
HOMELESS AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REALLY REMEMBER THAT AS WELL.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
RECEIVING A LOT OF CLIENTS WHO
ARE HIV POSITIVE.
COME THROUGH OUR DOORS WITH NO
INCOME AT ALL.
AND THAT HAS BEEN A TREND THAT
HAS BEEN REALLY.
TAKING OUR AGENCY.
TWO DIFFERENT LEVELS THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN.
IN A WHILE ALSO THINK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH THAT CLOSES PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEE IF FOR.
MY COLLEAGUE IF YOU'VE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS.
I WANT TO JUST REPEAT WHAT I
SAID EARLIER I'M JUST SO
GRATEFUL TO ALL OF YOU. FOR
BEING HERE FOR THE PANELISTS YES
BUT FOR THE REST OF YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE.
TO COME AND SHARE IN PUBLIC
COMMENT I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THAT.
BECAUSE AGAIN THE ENTIRE PURPOSE
OF ME INSISTING. THAT MY
COLLEAGUE CHAIRMAN DAVID CHIU
COME HERE AND TO HAVE A HOUSING
COMMITTEE HEARING. WAS I WANTED
HIM TO HEAR FROM YOU.
AND HE HAS HEARD FROM YOU AND IF
THERE IS ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
PLEASE
PROVIDED TO MY OFFICE ARE
PROVIDED DIRECTLY TO CHAIRMAN
CHOOSE.
.
TO HIS OFFICE OR THROUGH LEASE
OF COURSE.
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU.
AND NOW LET ME FIRST START BY
THANKING MY COLLEAGUE FOR YOUR
INVITATION AND YOUR PERSISTENCE.
AND TO ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
EXPERTISE AND YOUR AFRICA SENIOR
LEADERSHIP. DOES A STATE.
WE ARE AS I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING IN THE
WORST HOUSING CRISIS EVER WE'RE
NOT GONNA GET OUT OF IT IF WE
DON'T. WORK WITH EACH OTHER
AROUND THE STATE TO BUILD A
CONSENSUS AROUND THE HEART IDEAS
AND THE DIFFICULT SOLUTIONS
THAT WE HAVE TO COME TO TO TO
GET US OUT SO. OF THIS IS BEEN
REALLY.
INFORMATIVE FOR ME BUT
CERTAINLY.
IVEL LOT OF THOUGHTS AND WE'VE
ENGAGE IN A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
ARE IN THE CAPITAL BUT TO.
HEAR FROM YOU DIRECTLY ABOUT
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF WHAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT FROM
REDEVELOPMENT TO FINANCING. TO
HOMELESSNESS TO THE INTERSECTION
OF HOW OFTEN HOUSING.
REALLY REALLY HELPFUL SO I I
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING THE
INFORMATION THAT.
THAT.
THAT WE DISCUSSED HERE AND
CARRY THE CONVERSATION ON.
IT FOR TO COMING BACK TO SAN
BERNADINO AND HOPEFULLY SEE MORE
HOUSES BUILT SOMETIME SOON.
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AT THIS TIME THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED